believe it or not this may come as a
surprise to many of you but uh CNN
actually ran a segment where one of
their personalities Anna Navarro accused
Ron DeSantis of cheating and you know
what she said he did to game the system
arrested people committing voter fraud I
kid you not she said he arrested people
committing voter fraud prayed him around
created an election police he gained the
system and it's like wait wait you're
saying you're on CNN are saying that the
governor arrested people committing
fraud and then he won and that's why you
think he won I do not think she realizes
what she is saying and that is not the
Dig she thinks it is but we'll we'll
play this and then we'll talk all about
that we uh we also have a lot more
results coming in I suppose good news uh
literal good news I guess for uh
conservatives and Republicans Lauren
bobert has taken the lead so it's
looking like she's probably going to win
almost all the votes are in we'll see we
will see and then uh things are still
very very tight in the Cary Lake Race
she went down a little bit about 50 15
000 votes down
we'll get into all that stuff and of
course
how can we forget Alex Jones has just
been ordered to pay an additional 473
million dollars so he's got to pay like
1.4 billion dollars it's just it's just
not it's just not real money those
aren't real numbers that money doesn't
exist anywhere but of course that's how
it's been going and that's how it will
continue to go most likely so we'll talk
all about that before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member and uh sign up join us and you
can check out all of our members only
shows we'll have a members only show
coming up for you about 11 p.m and uh
you know what we're gonna do we have
these little Post-it notes that Milo
made because he was criticizing us about
the you know we're restricted by
YouTube's rules so I thought it'd be
really cool if
we send one of Milo's Post-it notes that
he wrote about censorship he wrote like
certain things you can't say on YouTube
and they're really funny with like sad
faces and stuff so what was that that
wasn't me
what was that not me weird anyway we're
gonna somebody who comments you know
we're gonna go through the comments on
the members only videos and then we're
going to pick some some people at random
and just be like hey we want to mail you
one of Milo's little notes on censorship
because we think it's actually really
funny it would be a cool thing to do for
you guys and I I figure you know we'll
probably do more stuff like that where
we can send you stuff that you know from
the show things that you know guests
give or Leave Behind signed stuff would
be really cool so if you want one of
Milo's Post-it notes that talks about
what YouTube Bands you can get it uh if
you're a member we'll get that sorted
and I do want to say this is it
this is the last promo that we have for
you
we have a song called uh genocide losing
my mind you can find out more at
losingmymind.com listen to the song buy
the song on iTunes it really really does
say 69 cents on iTunes and we're hoping
to smash into the Billboard Hot 100. we
will see and it's a big ask but I would
love it if the media was forced to write
about how we are criticizing them when
we put out a press release in the first
song they just basically told us Fu and
I read some of the comments that these
journalists wrote us like just insulting
us and saying Fu and it was like the
song Totally wasn't political okay so
this one's totally political it's
directly insulting the media we have
them singing for us about how they're
Liars trying to manipulate you and then
we put out a press release that overtly
was insulting towards them and now it
would just be really awesome if we hit
the nail in the head and got to chart
and they had they were forced to either
write about it or pretend like they
don't know it exists so with your
supports listening to the song on
YouTube buying it on iTunes genocide
Losing My Mind by timcast uh don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about all of the news and more we
have CJ
hi who are you I am CJ
um of I guess the deplorable choir and
I'm the president of the real Women's
Club
that's that's me all right right all
right we also have Chad Prather I'm good
yeah I'm glad to be here yeah host of
the Chad Prather show Appley name on The
Blaze and uh you are a real woman that's
good you are the vice president it might
if we determine that you were the vice
president of the real Women's Club yeah
yeah it's got to get me some Cloud on
the street somewhere with real women
everywhere that's right I love it right
on we also got Luke I I hear that's
trendy and very popular especially in
places like New York City anyway my name
is we are change.org I have one
important lesson for you guys and that
is that you cannot comply your way out
of tyranny it was true during covet it's
true now and it's true throughout all of
recorded human history if you agree you
could get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do that's why I'm here Splurge how are
you I'm serge.com doing well glad your
grandma hopes as well glad you're doing
as well all right
you you knew it was gonna happen here's
the first story we have for you I have
to pull this one up I heard this uh so
it's a tweet from end wokeness Anna
Navarro goes full election denier on CNN
this you have to here to believe but of
course you'll believe it uh here we go
yeah I told you he was going to win
bigly but listen wait wait I'm sorry she
said he's going to win bigly Trump
actually made that word a thing anyway
let's play it again yeah I told you he
was going to win bigly but listen Ron
DeSantis barely won in 2018 by 35 000
votes by the skin of his teeth against a
black Progressive little-known mayor
from Tallahassee Florida it didn't
yesterday he won by 20 percentage points
why because he gained the system because
he turned Florida into an unlevel
playing field they changed election laws
making it harder to vote by mail they
paraded a bunch of people black people
that they arrested for a voting fraud
and paraded them in front of national
media he created an election police he
also yeah I told you he was going to he
created an election police he paraded
people who were arrested for fraud he
made it the heart he made it harder to
vote by mail they call that cheating
it's kind of crazy to me when I first
heard this because she's basically
saying like if you stop people from
committing fraud Republicans will win
I'm like uh is that the message you were
going for cause that's what she said
that's crazy essentially I mean after
2000 Florida decided to invest a lot of
their money into voting because there
was a big problem there in 2000 and this
year they banned mail-in ballots they
banned ballot harvesting they they have
voter ID laws and they also created a
police force which I think I think was
pretty interesting but when we look at
Florida they were able to count 99 of
their votes by midnight they were able
to do a quick and effective job at it
unlike Arizona unlike a lot of other
states that that can't even count votes
so I I think it's pretty fair to say
that what they did in Florida was right
I think they they made sure that people
were voting who they were voting for and
made sure that there wasn't any kind of
theft or any kind of shenanigans going
on and I think that's one of the reasons
why DeSantis had such a big victory and
someone needs to tell those ladies
there's a whole bunch of people trying
to escape the blue states that the
policies they vote on made them need to
escape to Florida in this vote for
DeSantis you ever look and see just how
many influencers have now gone
to Florida all of them Dave rubin's in
what Miami now Luke was there but we
snatched him back I'm going to come back
eventually I think but look at all I
mean and you know forget the fact that
you know Anna Paulina Luna she won her
District but you've got so many folks
that are there now uh and again if you
look at the what did he win by against
Gillum like 1.8 percent and now this was
a massive blowout so you see see the
interpretation when I that I take away
from Anna Navarro is this what they're
not looking at is the fact that Ron
DeSantis put in policies that actually
worked made the state free made the
state great people liked it there were a
lot of people who didn't like Ronda
Sanchez to begin with maybe didn't vote
for him four years ago but this time
they said you know what this guy he's
done it right let's put him back in he
barely won last time he won by what 30
000. it was it was an extremely close
race and now how much did he win by what
is it one point one point five yeah 1.5
million votes that's that's a lot of
votes Trump didn't like it no obviously
he was angry at that Rhonda said flip
Tampa and Miami
these are I mean it's just it's it's a
it's apocalyptic for for the Democrats
in the state to to turn a city to a
republican majority is just it's just
insane yeah that's amazing no that's
that's the thing you know as Texans we
get frustrated with Greg Abbott because
Greg Abbott often gets lumped in as a
good conservative governor and he's not
uh you know what Rhonda Santos does well
the difference between him and Ron
DeSantis is Ron DeSantis does it and
then five days later has a press
conference about it and talks about how
he's already curb stomped everybody down
and done and it's working and then you
got a Greg Abbott who's like you know
putting his finger in the air to see
which way the wind's blowing and putting
a pole out there and he says oh we're
going to do that too aren't we bold and
then he never does it well exactly did
you hear Rhonda Santa's um his speech he
gave that night I swear I was wondering
if that was a swipe I have it because he
said he mentioned all the people that
just pull before they make decisions and
he said he makes decisions I said that
that's Abbott Greg Abbott spends 25 000
a week on polls he doesn't make a single
decision without polling wow you can't
trust the politician like that and you
can't try to trust the politician at all
in my opinion and my perspective but we
saw this also during covid specifically
with Ron DeSantis making a lot of the
bigger moves that were criticized by the
corporate media and then only later on
if DeSantis was able to survive the
storm did Texas Implement those same
kind of policies and I think covet is
the biggest thing that a lot of uh
people are paying attention to and
that's what really sets him aside from
Donald Trump that had the opposite
approach of what Ron DeSantis did and
when Donald Trump was criticizing Sweden
because they didn't lock down Florida
was was not locking down as well well
all you got to do is look at this the
bussing the illegals to these cities
okay all you got to look at as a
microcosm of everything else so Greg
Abbott was doing that he was sent him in
Washington D.C sending them to New York
City and again I I've never approved of
let's take illegals deeper into the
interior of the country that becomes a
problem but he was doing that to try to
make a point he was doing it over and
over again and Rhonda Santa sends 48
illegals to Martha's Vineyard
and over a course of what 36 hours makes
all the headlines all the news because
he sent them strategically to the right
place it wasn't New York it wasn't
Washington DC where they could just
blend in and quote assimilate now
Martha's Vineyard where he knew they
were going to stand out more than
anybody else and it was effective it was
effective we got more people talking
about it was the ultimate troll uh using
human beings which it's unfortunate
situation but but look at the attention
it garnered yeah it was unfortunate
because Martha's Vineyard was bigoted
and kicked them out
there and then they still patted
themselves on the back for like hand and
not blankets or something gave him a
Pop-Tart and said yeah you know
Amigos bye-bye they gave him a 50 gift
card
Joe Biden was trafficking uh was was
flying around these these kids and he
probably still is they they kept lying
and saying it wasn't happening then
video comes out out of Westchester New
York where the skies like if the
American people found out what we were
doing then you get video coming out of I
think it was Tennessee where they're
like yep the bite Administration is
flying these these illegal immigrant
children into various parts of this
country then you had that statement from
that sheriff in Ohio where he said ice
would be like hey can you hold these
guys temporarily for us while we're
processing they go yeah for sure and
then they ghost them just leaving them
there in Ohio
all of that was okay Rhonda Santa sends
one time 48 people and it was the
apocalypse it was it and listen if you
go down anybody that's a denier of that
and again for those who don't know I I
ran in the primary against Greg Abbott I
ran in the Republican primary against
Greg Abbott for governor of Texas all
right it was a I have no political clout
no desire to be a politician but if
everybody thought it was a joke if it
was a publicity stunt 19 months later
they knew I was serious we did what we
did and it was an educational thing we
got people involved in the primary that
had never been involved before you go
down to McAllen Texas you go down you
stand in the airport and you look around
you will literally see hundreds of
illegals walking around with the manila
envelope on the outside of it printed in
the English says I do not speak English
I need you to help me get to my gate you
don't know what's inside of the papers
or the envelope other than papers that
say we have a ticket to go wherever we
want to go in the country it's happening
they're moving them all over look at
that right there I mean and if you
listen my friend my friend Weston
Martinez that ran for uh land
commissioner he carries in his pocket a
a
piles one of these cards right here he
carries a pile of them in his pocket at
any given time and they're all Haitians
that are coming through the southern
border they were displaced after the the
hurricane or the Earth that's a fake ID
that was left here by Lord miles
Rutledge on his travels he was under the
Border he said there's done some he had
a stack of him he was like here I'll
leave this one yeah you can go down to
the you can go down the Rio Grande River
I mean you will find there's stacks of
those that's what I said yeah well and
the funny thing is is like you know
they're going to try to they well like I
said they pat themselves on the back for
welcoming welcoming them but they don't
even understand the bigger reason why
you want the Border closed is not only
for us because we can't house them just
like you couldn't in Martha's Vineyard
but it's also completely dangerous like
there's been record numbers of illegal
aliens die this year under the Biden
Administration it's unsafe for them too
it crimberates crime here but if you
have a heart for illegals which I always
have been trying to appeal for the
people and telling them why we want the
Border clothes but I I want to point
this out too um I just went and saw
wakanda forever black black panther too
I told you guys about it I don't I'm not
gonna spoil it because I know a lot of
people may want to go see it I thought
the movie was enjoyable and it was also
one of the most extremely racist films I
mean it's crazy the first black panther
was a an ethno nationalist versus like
an ethno supremacist that was the first
black panther the reason I bring this up
in this context because I will give you
guys a little bit of a spoiler the movie
was basically like I I don't want to
spoil too much but it was an extreme
racist stereotype about
um Mexican illegal immigrants and that's
the funny thing when you were telling me
I thought it was going to be like blacks
against white or or dominant Paradigm
kind of thing but it totally that's a
turn I didn't expect yeah if you watch
the trailer you will see that there's
two characters there's uh you know
t'challa has passed away that's that's
in the trail everyone knows that because
Chadwick Boseman passed a rest in peace
and uh in the movie you have wakanda
this African nation and then Neymar who
is another Marvel character is basically
a Mexican guy he's Yucatan Mayan so they
have a lot of Mexican you know Heritage
and symbols and stuff and this is what
the movie's about if you watch the
trailer you can basically understand
without me spoiling anything that um I I
can't get into it without spoiling a key
component of the film but
holy was it like
an overt message about
Mexicans and South American illegal
immigrants and I was just like yikes man
like that wow and I'm sure a bunch of
woke people are gonna are gonna
celebrate it oh for sure but I just had
to bring it up because I just saw it and
it's like on my mind I wish I could
spoil it it'd be so good but I can't I
was like shocked when you told me yeah
did you see it no I didn't see it I came
in like we were in the car coming back
from it and just like that whole movie
oh man I can't I can't spoil it I just
wish I could but it's wild it's wild
it's like Donald Trump is probably
sitting there pointing his finger like
that Leonardo DiCaprio like that that
getting y'all ever follow it there's a
guy on Instagram and followers he takes
the old like Justice League Comics his
name is Ace vain he takes the old
Justice League comics and he does the
voiceovers but but it's like he's black
right he's it's very much you know so so
they capture Aquaman and I'm not gonna
give this away I'm gonna do this
creatively they have to capture Aquaman
they got him in like a cage and he's
like I'm gonna do some medieval [ __ ] on
this dude and he's like what are you
gonna do to it man he goes I'm gonna
drown him
what so and then you telling me that
story reminded me a little bit of that
and of course yeah I just when you when
folks see the movie they'll do it
they'll know exactly six months you can
reveal it we it's just it's crazy that
we've got uh in politics the board are
such a big issue and then you literally
have this move this movie I'll I'll say
this thing I'll say one thing
it's not a spoiler it's in the trailer
in the trailer there is a scene showing
the the Mexican water people
entering wakanda
and so you get the point I'm gonna
explain it that's in the trailer but
like the ending was just like they may
as well have come out and just started
spitting racial slurs I was just like
it's funny though I bring it up just
because it's a such a big political
issue and like woke people have been
celebrating black panther like the first
movie as this like great Triumph of
diversity or whatever and I'm like it's
just one of like the whole thing is
racial racial stereotypes this is not a
spoiler it's just a scene in the movie
the the the wakandans are are control
are using computer controls by by
banging on drums and I was just I'm like
it was just way over the top way over
the top no condom forever yeah yeah well
let's do this let's jump to uh the next
big story
uh ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already heard Donald Trump is going uh
what does Curtis say postal on Ron
DeSantis
all right I'm gonna read for you the the
statement from Donald Trump he writes
News Corp which is Fox The Wall Street
Journal and the no longer great New York
Post bring back Cole is all in for
governor Ron Des sanctimonious an
average Republican governor with great
public relations who didn't have to
close up his state but did unlike other
Republican Governors whose overall
numbers for a republican were just
average middle of the pack including
coven and who has the ADV advantage of
sunshine where people from badly run
States up north would go no matter who
the governor was just like I did
Ron came to me in Desperate shape in
2017. he was politically dead losing in
a landslide to a very good agriculture
commissioner Adam Putnam
who was loaded up with cash and great
poll numbers Ron had low approval bad
polls and no money but he said that if I
would endorse him he could win I didn't
know Adam so I said let's give it a shot
Ron when I endorsed him it was as though
to use a bad term a nuclear weapon went
off years later they were the exact
words that Adam Putnam used in
describing Ron's endorsement he said I
went from having it made with no
competition to immediately getting
absolutely clobbered after your
endorsement I then got Ron by the star
of the democratic party Andrew Gillum by
having two massive rallies of tens of
thousands of people at each one I also
fixed his campaign which had completely
Fallen apart I was all in for Ron and he
beat Gillum but after the race when
votes were being stolen by the corrupt
election process in Broward County and
Rod was going down 10 000 votes a day I
sent in the FBI and the U.S attorneys
and the ballot theft immediately ended
just prior to them running out of votes
and sarri to win I stopped his election
from being stolen and now Ron D
sanctimonious is playing games the fake
news asks him if he's going to to run if
president Trump runs and he says I'm
only focused on the governor's race I'm
not looking into the future well in
terms of loyalty in class that's really
not the right answer this is just like
2015 and 16 a media assault collusion
when Fox News fought me to the end until
I won and then they couldn't have been
nicer or more supportive The Wall Street
Journal loved low energy Jeb Bush and a
succession of other people as they
rapidly disappeared from sight finally
falling in line with me after I easily
knocked knocked them out one by one we
are in exactly the same position now
they will keep coming after us Maga But
ultimately we will win put America first
and make America great again this has to
be one of the cringiest things I've ever
heard from Trump and it's sad it's very
very sad Rhonda Sanders didn't say
anything about him Trump comes out after
Ron's double digit a 20-point victory
and then is just for no reason insulting
Rhonda Santos yeah it's kind of a little
pathetic it's a sign of weakness you
know because you're you're what he's
doing is essentially spreading Division
and his comments began with covet
because that's one and again one of the
strongest talking points against Donald
Trump and where the two are the most
different Donald Trump told everyone to
lock down said we need 14 days to slow
the spread got Dr fauci to to Mark out
orders told everyone to listen to Dr
fauci launched operation warp speed told
everyone to take the vaccine when
DeSantis didn't lock down he didn't have
any mask mandates in his States and he
told people hey if you want to take the
vaccine take it but it's up to you and
your doctor to make those decisions for
yourselves that's the biggest difference
there and I think this is why Donald
Trump started by talking about kovid in
his kind of unhinged attacks against
DeSantis when it could have been a
moment of congratulations like hey
DeSantis you you did great I hope other
people in the party do great as well
maybe we should work together but but we
don't have any imagine if he said
instead of insulting Ron DeSantis if he
said I remember when Ron DeSantis came
to me and said I need your support and I
said Ron you're a good guy you have
great policies I am going to be there
for you and now we see just how
successful he's become imagine if you
just said that said I was proud to stand
with Ron DeSantis and I'm proud now to
see his success I'm glad that I I threw
my weight behind him when I did because
now we're seeing a true star that would
have come off as strong yeah well and I
think so many people followed Trump and
they were hoping to see more candid
candidates like Rhonda santis pave way
and do the same bold outspoken stuff
that Trump did and then so when you have
him he actually knocks them down it's
actually from somebody who loves Trump I
don't like to see that you want it as
many trumps you want a whole movement I
mean if you're a part of that Maga
movement you want more and more of that
and you don't want just Trump exactly
what happened When You're Gone Trump you
want to you know bring up a whole
another generation of politicians that
are going to be bold that aren't going
to be you know kissing media but and so
you get someone like that and Rhonda
Santas and then he
yeah yeah but Trump is up there when it
comes to age and there's a there's an
opportunity there to to help people to
build and grow but but that's not what
we have here so let me let me piss
everybody off so we don't need another
80 year old President we don't okay now
I supported Trump now when I I didn't
understand Trump 2015 but when I walked
into the voting booth there were two
boxes it was Hillary Clinton and not
Hillary Clinton I checked the one that
said not Hillary Clinton uh and we wound
up with Donald Trump now again I he
converted me he brought me over I I
could see through the the stuff I could
see through the if you will a comedic
timing that he has which is really
pretty damn good uh but he was
anti-establishment I think a lot of
people love that but they love that
aspect about him he wasn't one of those
Bolton paid for 50-year politicians as
we as we've become used to and people
will make the argument they'll say well
without Trump there would be no DeSantis
and maybe that's true maybe that's true
without Trump maybe there's no Warren
Buffett maybe there's no Marjorie Taylor
you should be like yes look at all these
people I've brought up versus right when
they succeed I mean you that's kind of
different yeah it's like obviously he's
threatened by him which is stupid he
even said you're starting to look like
and everybody says well it's 40 5D 18d
chess right Trump knows all he walks on
water right he's the Savior he's the
Messiah I get it everybody's knee-deep
in this cult did you know that
personality Donald Trump the name it
means Herald of the world ruler no so
Donald but it sounds like it should
Donald is uh I'm so I'm I'm being a
little um editorial with it but Trump
means like the trumping sound of the
Declaration right and Donald means World
ruler and listen I I was sitting with
Donald Trump Jr the night I CJ and I
went the night I decided I was going to
run for governor oh and I sing songs
about Trump
rally I love him we've been around I
mean obviously the point is we've put
our support well the point is is what
I'm scared of is he actually it's okay
it works when you do it to Ted Cruz I
mean we love Ted Cruz but you know he's
not likable you know
it works it works we all get a kick out
of it but when you go after somebody
that's done so much for America
it's like it's gonna rub your fan base
the wrong way and the other day I guess
it was yesterday on Truth Trump said now
that the election in Florida is over
everything went quite well shouldn't be
said that in 2020 I got 1.1 million more
votes in Florida than Ron D got this
year 5.7 million to 4.6 million just
asking so I tweeted it this morning I
mulled over it for 24 hours and I said
dumb
uh Trump's ego getting in the way again
and there's literally no justifying a
move like this now psychologically I I
agree with you Tim I don't think there's
any way you look at this it becomes
cringy people that want to see two
Heroes come together and say let's be a
Powerhouse but but remember that Meme
that it was the Babylon B they wrote an
article it said ingenious move Trump
supports impeachment forcing Democrats
to oppose you remember that Babylon B
article yeah and then they just wrote
basically you know Democrats now had no
choice you see this is my favorite
conspiracy theory here Donald Trump
knows no matter what he does they will
they will take the opposite side of it
so Trump starts going after DeSantis so
all the never trumpers all of the
moderates all and many Democrats are
going to be like screw you Trump I like
to scientists yeah that's wild [ __ ] but
I can see it Trump is I'm I'm kidding
honestly I think Trump is got an ego and
he's mad that DeSantis is doing so well
because he wants to run but uh we can
just imagine that Trump is actually so
Noble he's willing to sacrifice his own
image gotta wish to force him
listen we look we talked to Trump
Tuesday night right so we're sitting
there we did our panel discussion on the
blaze Sarah Gonzalez glidbeck we're all
sitting there and we had Trump for 15 20
minutes right and and three times Glenn
asked him he said hey you know you when
you announce on the 15th that you're
going to run for president Trump ignored
the question until the third time
finally quite honestly you're gonna love
what I gotta say You're Gonna Love it
you're gonna appreciate what I'm gonna
say you're gonna love it and it's like
your assumption is yeah he's going to
announce he's running for president I
can't in a million years imagine he's
going to say I'm going to throw all of
my power and my weight behind Iran
DeSantis who look I have no doubt I have
no question I mean even I'm not going to
quote Roger Stone but even Roger Stone
told me one time he's like I don't trust
Rhonda Santas he's to establishment
maybe he is to establishment but I'll
tell you the guy's done a hell of a job
but when When Donald Trump criticized uh
Ted Cruz there's legitimate things to
criticize Cruz on what is he criticizing
Ron DeSantis on I'm not seeing it why
hasn't he made a strong legitimate
argument about what exactly Ron DeSantis
has done he hasn't been doing it he
actually said what he did he was upset
that he didn't come out right saying he
wasn't going to run for president yeah
yeah and again that's right that's
that's belligerent insane kind of
thinking that that's absolutely based on
the ego and what is it doing it's it's
creating division amongst a party that
that again is fighting within the party
and and even that one side the the
anti-establishment faction which I think
is represented by Trump and DeSantis is
fighting within that party so so it's a
civil war within a civil war of this
political party which is spreading more
Division and of course making sure that
the that the populist branch of the
party will never get get any significant
strength they're they're the neocons are
happy when the neocons that are watching
this right now they're happy they're
cheering this on they're calling this in
the press the GOP Civil War and I'm like
yo the Civil War's in 2015. and Donald
Trump won and then was at war or he he
won he wins this fight in the primary
but then he's in this long battle with
the GOP establishment that civil War's
been going on if they're now claiming
this is a civil war they're admitting
Trump won that Maga won the Republican
party that's it
well and it did well never mind wouldn't
it be nice I mean in a perfect world in
my perfect world I could see Trump and a
DeSantis that come along and say you
know what we recognize the Democrats and
the Republicans are the flip side of the
same big government coin they're all
corrupt we've been screwed by the
two-party settlement system they
basically ruined a constitutional
republic let's start a whole other party
um
Libertarians but but how can they start
a party when they keep fighting each
other that's the problem my perfect
world but they're not going to do it but
but there was even a couple right-wing
hundreds that were talking about I'm an
interrupter my bad sorry no no no it's
just the right thing I just want to make
one really quick question I just want to
make one quick Point here there was a
couple right-wing pundits that were
making the call that DeSantis and Donald
Trump should run together and this was
going to be a dream ticket that could
definitely Dominate and beat the
Democrats and now they're that's that's
not gonna happen sorry go ahead no I I I
listen I got kids I always talk over
them I'm like listen to me sorry but I
was like you're saying how you know it
could be they're they're causing
everybody to look at them like this
fighting this infighting all the plan
and then all of a sudden they come out
holding hands it's the American dream
this could look a lot of people want to
believe that Trump's always playing
fourth dimensional chess like that
implies it's multi-layered and he's
traveling through time or something but
uh whether it's on purpose or not this
is owning the news cycle and that means
Democrats are never going to get a a
minute of of of time to talk right so
they've got no stars that Beto and
Abrams are their stars and they just
keep losing they're famous for losing
Beto's now lost what he heard three in
less than four years he's the best in
less than four years I want somebody I
was going to do it but I didn't have
time I want somebody to come out with a
meme that shows little African kids
wearing Beto shirts you know from after
the election and I want them to see like
these kids growing they've got a kid
that's Beto for Senate Beto for
president Beto for uh governor and just
they just keep growing in these shirts
uh and then you have a meme where
there's an outlet store called discount
clothing and it's all about no shirts
all the different kinds of beta
percentage for governor hey I hope he
runs again because that's an easy
feeling John cornyn in Texas for Senator
of Texas he'll probably run in corn into
a piece of trash but the uh to your
point Tim I agree with you I think that
uh you got Trump who I mean I'd love to
have the kind of power where you could
sit on the toilet in the West Wing at 3
30 in the morning freshly spray painted
orange and and just hair hasn't moved in
four days it just hit tweet you know and
just say Cafe and it controls the news
cycle for 36 hours right yeah I mean
that's laser pointer to cats kind of
power uh and he could do that he knows
he can do that and he's not even on
Twitter he's doing his own truth well
let's think about this if Trump really
was a smart guy right and I'm not I'm
saying you know I think Trump is a smart
guy but if he was like a tactful
Mastermind what if he really was
thinking I he he didn't like Luke
pointed out he didn't actually attack
the San just for anything he's attacking
him but not really criticizing him on
anything right what's the purpose of
that we're talking about it it's making
it look like Trump is whining and
doesn't like DeSantis it's giving to
Santa's the story now is he's like you
just said it's a big win but I was
bigger he's making the Press continually
report to Santos won by by Massive
numbers without actually attacking
DeSantis do you see what I mean it's a
good point but what if Trump is thinking
they will hate me no matter what I do if
I run but the Santa says my proxy if I
hate him he wins and then gives me
favors good point well Trump's been I
mean that's one theory that that needs
to be backed by some evidence a total
speculation yeah yeah but but Trump has
been attacking the Santos for a very
long time he's been making small Jabs
against him throughout the last few
months and years that that are becoming
pretty evident that there is a kind of
ego battle here I don't think it's for
the chess who in the world knows but at
the end of the day I think we should be
skeptical of DeSantis I think we should
be skeptical of Donald Trump in it but
right now DeSantis is really doing a lot
by not saying anything and by by not
reacting by not playing into the ego by
not counter-attacking a lot of people
are like wow uh he's handling this in in
a in a way better way than the former
president of the United States you know
I love uh I wake up after the midterm
and I see these posts where they're like
what happened last night this is Trump's
fault and all that stuff and I'm like I
don't know what's going on like did the
Republicans lost and I look and it's
like New York Times projects 20 200 224
seats for the Republicans and it's a
toss-up it might go to 51 in the Senate
maybe not and then I'm like okay so
these are this okay so they won wait
hold on these leftists are cheering
Colbert is gloating Jimmy Kimmel is
laughing they're posting pictures of
like a spattering of ketchup on the
floor and they're like yo we won and I'm
like Hillary Clinton she goes it turns
out women like their rights and they
vote and I'm like lady you lost like I
don't understand this means Nancy
Pelosi's done she's out this is like the
most powerful Democrat that has just
lost and now she's done and they're
cheering for this what do you call
someone who celebrates having lost
a crazy person a loser at minimum but I
don't understand I know you know we had
Milo on the other day and he mentioned
it's because the Republicans wanted
revenge and I was like oh gee I guess
I'll have to settle for winning I get it
you want revenge no I totally understand
a blowout Landslide would feel great
sorry guys you'll have to accept just
having one you just have to one you just
won but it's also important to note here
that Ron DeSantis did endorse candidates
in this election that didn't win so he
doesn't also have a perfect record as
well Donald Trump also endorsed
candidates didn't win but Donald Trump's
getting a lot of the criticism and a lot
of fact from Flack from it some people
say it's deserved some people say it's
not I I think what happened in
Pennsylvania with Oz is the criticism
there is absolutely deserved uh I think
what happened in Georgia he criticized
the candidate there that that one so
again it's a mixed bag of what's going
on here but when we look at the midterms
I mean this is the best midterm for
Democrats since then since 1986. for
Democrats uh for Democrats yes and Biden
uh Biden had a better midterm than
Clinton and Obama this is one of the
best performing midterms for incoming
political party in the last 20 years so
so there's one reason for it I I think
there's a lot of reasons there's one
reason it's not because of policy it's
not it's because of mail-in ballots and
redistricting I think it's just mail-in
ballots Sunny host and on The View
admitted whether accidentally or
otherwise it should committed voter
fraud now this is one person I'm not
saying it's swing swung in black or
anything like that uh and maybe if you'd
like to make an excuse for her as to
what she meant feel free to do so
but we had this um this viral clip where
she gets she's on her phone and Whoopi
Goldberg she's like get off your phone
you know Heavens or whatever and then
Sonny's like it was my son he was he was
messaging me to make sure you know that
uh I his absentee about that that I did
that and then it's like it's a weird
thing to say that I did that like ex
what does that refer to and then she
said I had trouble voting for him today
full stop she said she did vote for him
that is admitting to voter fraud now
immediately left personalities came out
and started saying she means that she
dropped off his ballot for him it's like
sure okay I get that where's her son at
where's her son that she had his ballot
and he couldn't drop drop it off well
apparently it was reported that her son
was in Massachusetts while she was in
New York
so why did the ballot go to the house in
New York you would have to believe that
the Sun
ordered an absentee ballot not to where
he is in Massachusetts which is what
absentee is for but to his own home in
New York where he could have just voted
in person but maybe he did it because he
knew he wasn't going to be there on
Election today but was going to be there
you have to believe then that he ordered
it went to visit his family filled
everything out signed it dated
everything sealed it up close it put it
down then left
then called his mom and said hey can you
drop my ballot off for me you'd have to
assume that he didn't just drop it in
the mailbox as per what absentee ballots
are for he didn't just take it with him
back home to mail that he literally went
home filled it out dropped it left I
think the simple answer Occam's razor is
that she committed voter fraud I don't
think voter mail-in voting is overtly
about voter fraud I'm not saying that
either the reason mail-in voting was was
the Democrats the reason Democrats did
so well right now nothing to do with
Trump they're saying Trump dragged the
party no establishment Republicans were
pulling funding from from Key races
everybody knows that and the bigger
issue is Democrat turnout was very good
youth turnout was very good and it's
this simple
mom goes to her Suburban mom goes to her
kids and she says kids our ballots came
fill them out and the kids say sure
whatever I guess who am I voting for and
just fill it out for the Democrats and
then they do those are real ballots
filled up by real people those kids
normally would not have voted they don't
know they don't care it has nothing to
do with them but their mom asked them to
now the steel man argument from the
Democrats of course is so what real
people voted what's your point my point
is people who don't care about the
system are voting and that's bad for the
system in the long run you can argue
that it's good because your policies are
winning but yo gas prices through the
roof inflation through the roof people
are not doing well and it's because we
have we have voters who have nothing no
stake in the system and don't care and
are only voting because it's just you're
tripping over ballots it's that simple
plus plus real quick and and I think 39
States about harvesting is legal so now
you have Democrat nonprofits legally
going to places where people normally
don't vote and saying fill it out and
I'll take it from you and that's
massively increasing voter turnout well
if you're looking at the Democratic base
this midterm election there was a lot of
unmarried women that heavily voted uh
Democratic there was also a lot of 18 to
20 year olds that voted uh in favor of
the Democrats over 70 percent of them
voted for for Democrats I think a lot of
this also has to do with big Tech
censorship and institutions like Tick
Tock Banning right-wingers and
conservatives and allowing other people
to have those kind of voices there and
when you have those key demographics
voting obviously they're going to be
voting in favor of policies and fit them
but I also want to point this out
because for those that are fans of the
show you know I pointed this out two
years ago or a year and a half ago
if a Democrat nonprofit goes to New York
City Universal mail-in voting is
everywhere they walk into one tall 30-40
story building they knock on a door no
answer they spin around another door
knock someone answers within the span of
a couple minutes they could talk to
dozens of people within the span of an
hour they've talked to hundreds these
are legitimate votes and it's a
legitimate practice but Universal
mail-in voting disproportionately
benefits dense urban populations if a
republican wants to go door to door
they're mostly in rural areas you'd have
to get in your car drive to a house
knock on the door no one answers get in
your car driving the next house that
took five minutes Democrats not gonna
door no answer walk 10 feet knock in the
door no answer walk 10 feet knock on the
door so long as we play this game of
let's make it easier for everyone to
vote the procedure outright favors
Democrat strongholds now DeSantis I
think has proven
If he if you play the game right if
you've got good policy you can still win
if you win the cities so perhaps we
should either do away with universal
mail and voting because I certainly
think that's a big problem not because I
think people shouldn't be voting I think
it's a problem for a system when people
who don't want to vote just vote because
like people have to know what they're
choosing to do it you have a right to
own a gun doesn't mean every person
should just own a gun I think most
people should own a gun but just because
you have the right to do it doesn't mean
you know you can be just irresponsible
with it yeah
we're in a situation I mean look we've
got we've got I think that the election
system in America systematically flawed
uh you know the radical thing that I've
suggested over and over again is legally
we should just wipe the ballots uh the
the voter rolls clear let everybody just
like your passports expired it's time to
go back and re-register let's see if
you're alive let's see if you're legal
let's see if you live where you say you
live let's go back there and see who you
should be there you should have to
register every election I I think you
should actually and you and you should
go back in there and you say okay I mean
people do that they renew their driver's
license they renew their passports they
do all these things I think that you
should have a voting day an election day
not an election season you should you
should register for every election by
going and be and and it can I don't care
if it's online quick 30 second thing to
be like this is my current address and
if you don't you don't vote yeah like so
back in the day we had voting where it
was like you had to be a landowner right
and you'd be a man okay so we don't
agree with those things today but you
need to understand the context back in
the day the the man thing yeah obviously
we've done away with with all that stuff
you know men and women can both go vote
19th Amendment but the reason it was
land-based was because we didn't have a
DMV to go get an ID right how did how
did we know you actually live there oh
you live in this house so you live here
yeah when we started moving into the
space of rentals and um you know tenants
not ownership we're like okay well these
people they do live here we know they
live here they can vote so because we're
a community
what ends up happening is you had Andrew
Yang say he was going to move to Georgia
back in 2020 to help uh um who was who
was running uh it was um
it was Abrams who was running against he
yeah he wanted to move to Georgia to
help the Democrats Warnock was running
yeah why not he so Andrea is like I'm
gonna move down there and it's like so
hold on you're not a member of our
community you're not voting for us for
what makes our lives better you're
voting for The Nation by moving into our
space yo that's crazy that shouldn't be
that way now however
you're allowed to move I get it that
being said I think it would make sense
if you were after every election voter
vote there's no such thing as a voter
rule you're not registered anymore when
election season comes Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram whatever can do a
reminder being like time to register to
vote and then you say yes I live here I
want to vote this place they say you got
it we've tracked your address then when
you show up you present proof that's who
you are and where you live and you say
that's me and they go send in your vote
yeah and it was also off not worn out
you got 10 million people watching this
thing I got to correct that because I'm
the one that's wrong the Republicans
really do you know if they're good for
anything they'll
it
like what was it the HB what you know
it's like unfortunately all the voter
like any like they try to do I can't
talk anymore you can I tell you I'm like
Biden I need someone to finish my
sentences for me I look at you don't
look at me I'm just as good as fetterman
and Biden I'm over here stumbling over
my words just
what am I saying
I agree with Michael malice
um I don't know his full position on
fetterman but I think fetterman in the
Senate is a gift is a big big gift hear
me hear me people if the Republicans had
the Senate it would be better Iran sorry
not wrong Rand Paul would be chair of
the health uh committee or whatever I
forgot the full name and that means he's
going to be able to you know ask some
serious questions about fouchy and all
that stuff he's done it already but what
could they really do there's a chance
the Republicans will take the Senate
with the Georgia runoff we'll see
but with Fetter men in this means the
real prize 2024
it's it's it's it's fetterman's an
advantage think about all of the videos
that are going to come out all of the
memes all of and it's sad really I mean
I don't like it that Biden is out of his
mind that fetterman is is brain damaged
these people shouldn't have run but you
know what they did so now the now
they're the Democrats are going to get
to withstand they're gonna have to
figure out how to get past
two years of John fetterman not
understanding words
he you see the video where he said he
celebrated the death of Roe v Wade yeah
he's not with it and they got it
congratulations they're gonna have to
hide this man hey I've been calling for
him to run for president of the United
States we have Biden we might as well
have fetterman and MSNBC is joining my
calls officially saying hey fetterman
could could potentially be president
unironically no yes yes
I believe I tweeted it on my Twitter
page uh Luke we are change and it was
MSNBC it was the video that I started
off my YouTube uh no no I played it on
my YouTube video today as well it'll be
on my Twitter uh but but the memes they
they are very spicy already I I like to
post spicy memes but some of the federal
federal means are even too much too
spicy for me to be honest watch this
video wait wait wait gotta listen to
this video by MSNBC because they're
supporting what would I put out there a
couple weeks ago so we're gonna do a new
segment and let's pull up this clip we
got this tweet from Mr Lou gradkowski
himself
yes MSNBC is behind my idea fetterman
Biden 2024. zetterman as a nominee at
some point for president
um I know there's some variables
obviously but yeah but I just you know
what he did in the in the super red deep
red parts of Pennsylvania and the way
that he ran ahead of Biden as you were
saying ran ahead of trump I mean it just
makes it makes you wonder about his
future okay uh I'm sorry if you read
hold on hold on hold on fetterman in the
Senate as a Democrat I can understand
why there's a why you know there's a
there's a closed door but open window
there for the next two years Democrats
are going to have to answer for a man
who's not all with it who's got brain
damage in the Senate and it's going to
be amazing talking points for
Republicans but fetterman as the
president no no no no there's nothing
after that I mean you want to sacrifice
the country for four years so that you
can try and win after that I I'm sorry
I'm not on board I'm I'm messaging my
guys right now we're making officially
Biden fetterman 2024 trucks that are
going to be available on the best
political shirts right now probably by
the end of tonight sorry go ahead no
it's it's um
you know a lot of folks think that maybe
moving fetterman into that position was
a way of putting his wife in position uh
that he's going to become you know here
in the next I don't know less than six
months he's going to be unable to
perform his duties or whatever after
he's sworn in and it puts his wife in a
position to fill his fill his seat uh
we'll see I mean either way you're
dealing with insanity
across the board I mean you're dealing
with Insanity with this thing the fact
that they they looked at a guy and you
know you look at the memes the fetterman
means I put one on my Facebook earlier
today and people said you know this is
way beneath you and I'm like you have no
idea what's beneath me you don't know
how low I can go but uh they said you're
making you have no sympathy for a stroke
victim I mean my father ultimately died
from his stroke so I it's not when I'm
making fun of his Strokes he was a [ __ ]
before he had a stroke uh and again if
if he's a stroke victim then his family
should have had sympathy and never put
him up there they should have pulled him
off that platform like if he's that
impaired that he can't he's a senator
for Christ's sake if he's a senator and
uh he can't handle some ridicule or a
meme about him then what the hell are we
doing I think they just like electing
people that they can control well he's
100 though absolutely like like that
that guy in Pennsylvania who was dead
I said that on Twitter people that were
dead there were three people there's
three not in Pennsylvania but they were
not in Pennsylvania there was one in
Massachusetts one in Pennsylvania and
then one in somewhere else
yeah I said are we supposed to have
sympathy for the dead God too well and
what about the person that was running
against them like do they not
I'm surprised the Democrats didn't dig
him up and like hey
put his hand on the Bible I recently
learned that you can't defame dead
people
so now we can say Democrats elected
fraudsters con artists and rapists oh
they're dead you can't defame them
that's true no I don't want to disparage
the people who died I got no beef they
say oh you have no sympathy for a guy
well I have no sympathy for the person
that's dead either they're dead but I
mean you still elected them Hugh McKean
apparently died and was elected and then
Barbara Cooper she died in October
but seriously to the person that ran
against them
they lost to a dead person what do you
do what do you do next that's worse than
us like that's pretty embarrassing well
you if you're dead if you are dead your
votes should be eliminated period just
gone right don't know don't care no
special election your votes are gone if
you vote for a dead person your vote is
gone you voted for a dead person you're
punished like imagine you're playing
basketball somebody and you throw the
ball just out of the Court okay that
that's your that's a foul or something
what is that out of court or whatever no
yeah out of bounds we don't give you
points for it we don't say hold on let's
let's let's let's start over again and
we'll figure this out no no no you you
screwed up that's right and I understand
that after a certain point like if you
die after a certain point you you name
there's a good chance you'll be on the
ballot our good friend Serge Summers he
died in the middle of his campaign oh my
God you voted for it I voted you voted
for it so let's call you out on that I'm
a hypocrite he's a good friend of ours
and you gave him a little honor it's bad
I didn't he didn't but he died on the
campaign Trail he died in a car wreck I
got to read this super chat from James K
James this was a grand slam he says
Biden fetterman 2024 it's a no-brainer
that was a good one that was real good
anyway on to the dead people who won
um amazing
congratulations y'all so what is it I
mean look Republicans have elected dead
people before too because people will
like these some to these Democrats I
think they died in October or you know
at least one of them did and so people
maybe just didn't realize the person
died like they knew who the person was
maybe they or I got to be honest I think
they just show up they hit the D and
they walk out oh yeah that's probably
true they don't know who they're voting
for well a friend of mine he even he got
Biden that calls out for dead people
yeah well I mean yeah yeah oh man he did
I mean I think I think Biden's at that
stage in life where his his toes were on
the precipice of the Eternal so he's
already seeing into you know the nether
regions and he's just seeing people
there floating around and he was there
yeah he didn't want to see if she's
there yeah where is she is she here well
you see he's trying to shake hands with
the air all the time yeah yeah this is
he's got his toes are the president of
Eternity yeah
this is uh shout out to Sheamus of
Freedom twins this is a good it's a good
horror uh uh bit Biden's so close to the
other side that he's starting to see
through the veil seeing dead people I
see dead people these six seven cents
whatever you know the thing uh but I've
got a friend who said he was at the
polling place and he goes up to the uh
the voting deal and he puts his thing in
it there's two girls young girls that
are standing there and one of the girls
says I don't know who any of these
people are I don't know what to do and
the girl beside her said just vote
Democrat
and that goes right back to your point
like if you're gonna do that stay home I
mean our country went from you got to be
a landowner you had the man voted for
the household I mean there were certain
requirements that you had and now you've
got any person that's brain dead out
there casting a vote because that's what
they're doing and I remind people voting
is not a right it is a privilege in this
country we have the rights that are that
afford US certain privileges you don't
have the right to vote you have the
privilege to vote it's it's a thing that
you should take very responsibly I mean
I might for instance I moved three
months ago four months ago from Fort
Worth Texas down to the Houston area I
changed my address changed everything
changed it with the secretary of state
to give me a new polling place I still
because the state did not change my
polling place I still had to go back to
Fort Worth Texas three and a half hours
from where I'm living now go back to
Fort Worth Texas and vote on Tuesday
election day and do it and listen I was
nervous because I thought I'm going to
get up here they're going to run my
driver's license and say well these
addresses don't match yeah I I still had
to fill out a form that said change of
address with the polling place and do it
so I I so again it's racist it's racist
that I had to do this but you know uh I
had to fill out another Form and I said
this this you're actually asking me to
write on this form the same things that
are on my driver's license why am I
doing this and they said just do it I
think it should be harder to vote it
should be harder to vote I think voting
is
it's a duty it's responsibility and it
is you saying I want certain things for
this for this country for the city for
this County whatever
the Democrat policy is let's just get as
many votes as possible we don't care
about the quality of the votes it gives
us power that's why they want 16 year
olds to vote right I think voting should
be hard but it should be this hard you
have to get up and go vote yeah
that's it yeah forget that drop forget
that mail in forget all of that stuff I
mean again if you're in firm your
military your law enforcement on duty
the stuff like that I understand there
are special concessions for that but the
guy that doesn't want to get up and go
should not vote no if you if if you
don't want to be there you shouldn't be
that's just the way it is
I mean it's frustrating to me tomorrow's
Veterans Day right I don't know when
this air is this we're live so this this
thing so we're Veterans Day tomorrow
right when you we went to Antietam today
we went we went over there and you go
over there 22
717 I think men died that day fighting
each other Americans fighting each other
you go to the graveyard and it is a sad
reminder not only brother against
brother Clash I mean that's the
bloodiest battle in the Civil War but
then you think about Normandy and you
think about you know the the millions
that died in the world wars and and you
look at the Afghanistan of evacuation
and the 13 that died there and the just
senseless stuff that goes on you're like
you got men and women that put on
uniform every day with a willingness to
serve sacrifice give their lives for our
Liberty our freedom our ability to have
those privileges I mentioned and you
don't do it you just don't do it you
don't give a [ __ ] enough to go out there
and study and see what's best to protect
your freedoms these guys died they bled
they sacrificed they go on deployment
nine ten months out of the year to stay
away from their children and you can and
you don't you can't read a book you
can't Google something to see if John
fetterman's a well idiot it's like you
said people had things have not gotten
bad enough for people to want to vote or
to change the way this is what happens
when we live in a world of manufactured
oppression and not real oppression
they've never suffered they've
manufactured victimhood they've told
themselves they're victims and and they
haven't done without food they haven't
done without water I mean unless you
live in you know Mississippi Jackson
Mississippi and there's sludge coming
out of your faucet for two weeks but
they haven't done without and so now
what they're saying is oh I got it so
hard I can't go if if you got it so hard
you can't go vote have you seen the
video of the Starbucks employee crying
about having to work yeah hours yeah it
was the funniest who's a trans
who's a trans person I don't know if you
caught that that was the other thing she
was complaining about was they were
misgendering and and that was the other
thing and which I think honestly was
probably the the Catapult that pushed
her into making the video anyway because
that was the stressor that was that was
the impression but you know and and
it the story wasn't about someone being
mean to this person it was just that
people kept misgenderings I grew my
feared out everything well I got to pass
I'm not I want to be careful because I
don't know if the individual was male
wanting to be a woman or a woman want to
be a male I mean you got to assume you
know she didn't
they didn't say so we don't really know
and she said I grew my beard out and
everything I think that was the quote Oh
okay but but the issue is so like look
at America right now you go across I
mean I travel the country I do I'm in 35
States a year doing live comedy shows
I'm all over the place 200 000 miles a
year in the air everywhere I go across
the country I was in Seattle last week
everywhere you go they went from having
Help Wanted signs outside of the
restaurants to saying please be patient
with our staff yep yep I saw that uh
it's a weird Trend if you think about
that I went to uh we were going down to
the Virginia Safari
and we drove through New Market it's
really cool when you're out here by the
way because all the Civil War histories
it's incredible yeah and we went to this
little restaurant and they had a big
sign saying please be patient with our
staff no one wants to work anymore no
joke I tweeted a picture of it out uh
take the picture and it's just it's it's
crazy to me I'm like where are all these
people where'd they go yeah they did
they get raptured or something oh no no
no no they got their checks in the mail
now they don't want to work well but
they're not doing that anymore so we
went out uh several times now uh a few
weekends ago we went to a theme park and
it was the Halloween party oh yeah
completely dead yeah completely empty 50
people maybe in this theme park and
we're just like what is going on yeah
like where is it okay maybe more than
maybe about 50 people I think I saw and
if you wanted to go on a ride you had to
go to the ride and there was no one
Manning it and then text a phone number
and someone would come and press the
ride button for you
Watson on you there's no shame in our
culture anymore nobody feels shame
nobody's ashamed of anything everyone's
proud there's no work ethic because
there's no shame in doing a poor job I
don't know if they're prouder they've
just been told it's okay to be a victim
and well they should be ashamed to sit
at home and but they're not I wanna I
want to uh you mentioned people are
getting their checks I want to pull up
this tweet from the red-headed
libertarian who says this might be my
finest prediction in one image the
red-headed libertarian said we are
totally going to find out in
mid-november that no one's getting their
loans forgiven LMAO Biden you Playa yeah
and then we have November 10th 808 PM
breaking federal judge rules Biden's
plan to cancel hundreds of billions of
dollars of student loan debt is
unconstitutional and must be vacated and
all of these people they ran these
videos where it was like cash in your
pocket cashing and it's like it's like
someone taking cash and it was like vote
for Biden all these young people this is
the problem with low information voters
make the voting age 50. I don't care
these young people are like hey did you
hear Biden's gonna give me money oh vote
for him and then they do well why am I
getting my money now because he lied to
you dude he has a problem we're we're
old people we've all been through this
young people they haven't experienced it
so fool me once shame on you fool me
twice shame on me these young people
were just fooled for the first time I
don't blame them they were trusting
Americans who said this guy says he's
going to help me out and sure enough
they got played now I just hope each and
every one of you Democrats young people
who thought Joe Biden was going to give
you cash and help you out realizes he
lied to you I ain't telling you to vote
Republican but just remember how they
lied to you because it will happen again
no 100 there was never a plan to do that
there was never a plan like you remember
when Joe Biden said uh Bill back better
is going to pay for itself
I mean that was a fun idea that was a
fun idea or the inflation reduction act
that has 80 000 IRS agents pretty much
wrote 87 000. it's gonna go after the
little person like that only has a
little bit in their account well yeah
you remember what the media did with
Donald Trump saying that Mexico was
going to pay to build a wall and then
Joe Biden comes along with a bill back
better I like I remember and which again
his inflation plan is nothing but a you
know climate change protection policy
right there I remember when they came
out with a green New Deal and AOC was
just a champion for that thing it looked
like a fifth grader wrote something in
crayon right nobody believed that there
would be a 91 trillion dollar
infrastructure rebuild nobody believed
that because what's a trillion nobody
knows what a trillion is they say
trillion and we just White Noise it
right and because nobody understands
what that number means we just throw
that around like it's no big deal but by
God I mean between modern monetary
Theory the ESG scores uh they're
believing that deficit and debts are
good things uh a cashless Society World
economic Forum all this stuff going on
and now you see what's going on I mean
Joe Biden actually flipped the script
the other day by saying the quiet stuff
out loud and saying oh we're going to
get rid of all these coal plants we're
going to get rid of all this stuff we're
gonna We're not gonna have that we're
gonna shut them all down we're gonna
have win we're gonna have solar they're
telling us what what they're doing they
don't care you know they don't care if
you're you know they've got what was
their deal we're gonna we're gonna you
spend 500 000 to winterize your home and
we'll give you a 300 tax credit this is
the end of the year that's the inflation
plan this is what you have you have
college students who are broke and in
debt they don't own property they own
nothing yeah and they're unhappy and so
then you have working Americans who
either own a home through loans
inheritance or maybe have a vehicle or
maybe maybe you're still renting but
have family and have responsibilities
those people are paying attention to why
their lives are being destroyed why is
my gas so expensive why can't I find
work why are the specialty jobs going
away they get mad at Democrats young
college students who are getting free
money they're using loan money to live
off of they don't have to work for
anything they just don't want to pay
loans the Democrats just offered them
the entire world
that's it I knew a guy he had student
loans and what did he do just party
that's that's it I mean but this was
this was normal in Chicago CJ tons of
tons of people hey they get student
loans and they go party I mean these are
for school and then they go party on the
weekends and I'm like you're doing no
work
you're going to school and now you want
me to pay your bills
um I'm sorry that just doesn't make
sense but it's kind of crazy that
Millennials I think they were only like
two points behind we were I'm a
millennial two points behind voting
um
Republicans versus Democrat they because
they're having babies now they're
growing up they have jobs and so where
they came out for like Obama but I in
the midterms I'm pretty sure they were
almost close to even I mean we always
make fun of Millennials but they were
voting Republican more this time around
well they have responsibility yeah yeah
their payments there's mortgages we grew
up yeah that's the thing so when I was
when I was working in Hollywood and and
out there you know my agent my manager
out there my manager had a guy that
worked for him and and uh he's a black
guy he worked on he'd worked on several
several Studio lots and stuff and and
we'd go to dinner and and Fred he was he
would say man I'm a Democrat because I
grew up a Democrat I grew up my family
was Democrats I've never known anything
different and my manager Arthur he would
say it's because you haven't made any
money yet yep you haven't made any money
yet when you make a little money you'll
you'll change and this was a guy in
Hollywood this was a manager who's been
you know 40 years in the television
industry out there who where if you're
you're anathema I mean you're a curse
you're ostracized you're outside of the
gate man you you were shunned if you
come out as a as a conservative who's
saying well yeah but you're not
conserving because you're not having
made any money yet it's a kind of one of
those Open Seasons wasn't the Biden
Administration meeting with the
influencers on tick tock to get all
those Jen's ears or did I dream that
well I mean we had the Jonas brother he
had everybody from the Jonas Brothers to
the the Dylan Mulvaney at the White
House so obviously he's doing that yes
yes
so
I'll tell you we're in a situation where
this is a controlled fault that this is
not even control they're trying to
control the downward spiral they're
crashing the plane we know the plane is
crashing we know that they want this
economy in shambles we want everything
done it it just done away with it things
that we've held valuable in traditional
in America and uh they don't care they
know that they can do this pin all the
blame on a Joe Biden who he ain't got
along like I said his toes are on the
precipice so they can do that well and
they don't they don't care he doesn't
have to campaign he can lick the windows
in Delaware it doesn't matter what he's
doing it doesn't matter what he's doing
it doesn't matter what he says the other
day they just asked him they said what
are you going to do to improve over
what's happened in the last two years he
said nothing well and I think they know
that it creates chaos and Chaos creates
fear and then they know that they can
control you once fear sets in and then
you're going to always vote for him we
saw that the last two years yes that's
all they got is fear you know well
Republicans are going to need more than
whatever it is they're offering to
because they The Establishment doesn't
want to The Establishment wants to stay
the uni party they want to they want to
keep that deal but that Deal's done Maga
came and it's not so much about Trump
anymore I mean you got DeSantis now and
if these if the if the establishment the
leadership doesn't realize they're you
know what I'll put it this way I think
they're willing to sacrifice victory for
as long as it takes they will just say
we don't care they're the same thing as
the Democrats so they'll just keep
sitting back and letting you know actual
Americans suffer hoping that eventually
Maga stops it's not going to I think the
one thing that needs to happen right now
for all the Republicans going in is just
absolutely reject McConnell and McCarthy
100 it's gone nope not gonna happen
under no circumstances sorry you tell
them you know for all these new members
of Congress you can be like there is
nothing on God's green earth that will
make me support you as Speaker you
better pick somebody else anyone else
but there but you know the problem is
we've had people come in here who are
just like well you have to I'm like no
you don't you can you can say have fun
have fun bring Pelosi back I guess see
that's the thing I've called it the good
old boys club forever you know you
you've been a member of this country
club for 30 years now it's time for you
to be the chairman of the board it's
your turn
strong language screw that I mean we've
got to screw that that's that's I mean
put Marjorie Taylor green makers
absolutely let's have at it let's have a
free-for-all yeah no no hands down uh
if I I think the challenge though as I
said is they would give up they would
say okay then we'll sabotage yet if you
try to go against us the establishment
so where do you go from there I guess
keep running
keep
getting new people and just wait I think
before we we fix social media this
problem is going to keep happening I
think social media has far of a bigger
impact on people's perceptions and
realities than we could even realize and
I think a lot of them are being
manipulated by the DHS by the FBI by the
doj that have their hands in big Tech
social media and and are deciding who
has a voice and who hasn't and I truly
do think that with this midterm that the
the big Tech social media censorship had
far more of an impact than a lot of
people realize I think what we saw also
in 2020 with Mark Zuckerberg spending
419 million dollars to help people vote
an effort that predominantly helped the
Democrats I I think that also had a big
impact also also in Florida where Rhonda
santis made sure that he passed the law
Banning what he called Zucker bucks that
couldn't be used in his state so I think
that also played a role in Florida
having such a significant Victory here
what Ron DeSantis seeing hey this big
Tech social media guy is trying to
influence this by putting his money in
there let's make sure his money doesn't
go to Florida and I think this is one
reason why Ron DeSantis had such a
victory because Mark Zuckerberg wasn't
able to have his own light needs to win
well and I think also that's why you
have Biden saying we need to investigate
Elon Musk now because they don't want
that Free Speech platform these people
are evil and I'll tell you why they this
woman gets up and she says should we be
investigating Elon Musk in the Saudi
billionaire investor and Biden's like we
should be looking into it that investor
was an original investor he already had
a billion plus in Twitter before Elon
stepped in oh but now and they ignore it
and and a lot of people not just Maga
people were saying hey shouldn't we take
a look at this because this isn't
influencing our politics now that Elon
stepson all of a sudden they're coming
I'm going oh what a problem we have here
these people are evil man let's let's
look at a couple of things in the last
two years under the quote-unquote
pandemic which by the way if we ever
have a real pandemic I'm dead because
I'm not getting vaxxed or anything else
I'm not doing any of that stuff I mean
no experimental stuff
but the thing is in fact I'm thinking
about getting my vasectomy reversed
because this stuff is going to be like
the new crypto
this is new Bitcoin uh right here and so
here's my thing we look at all the
tyrannies we came under the stuff that
was revealed America is held together by
a three-quarts trend okay the media
education and the courts we've lost the
media we've lost education we've barely
holding on to the courts right barely at
least we saw with the overturning of Roe
v Wade that the courts came out in favor
of the constitution in that case put the
rights back into the in favor of the
states making their own decisions but
look at all the tyrannies that are there
and we got to be real careful because
you've got medical tyranny we saw that
you got corporate here and you got big
Tech tyranny that we're discussing
you've got big government which you even
big government that's bureaucratic
tyranny because we're being ruled not by
elected representatives but by 2.5
million unelected bureaucrats in
Washington DC who are getting paid to
rule over us uh you got educational
tyranny you got the mainstream media
tyranny and at some point in time I'm
trying to figure out when we start
spilling tea into the harbor right
because this is this is [ __ ] and
we're looking at all this stuff and
there's no end in sight for it you said
the courts were hanging by a thread we
got the story from the AP Alex Jones
ordered to pay 473 million dollars more
there you go to Sandy Hook families so
uh 1.44 billion okay Connecticut Judge
Barbara Bellis imposed the punitive
damages on the Infowars host and Free
Speech system Jones reportedly told his
millions of followers yeah you get the
point the record clearly supports the
plaintiff's argument the defendant's
conduct was intentional and malicious
and certain to cause harm by virtue of
their infrastructure ability to spread
content and massive audience including
info Warriors I think it's all lies I
thank Alex Jones is a guy who goes in a
show and says things he thinks and he's
often wrong and uh he has free speech
rights to do it he doesn't have a free
speech right to defame people but I
believe he only defamed one person
explicitly I do think he was wrong to
say this and I do think it did cause
damages but this court in my opinion has
delegitimized Itself by saying a
gajillion bajillion Megabucks they may
have well just said you know the meteor
made of gold it's just it doesn't exist
it's not going to happen a death penalty
why don't you just give him the death
penalty I mean I mean
yeah it's not that far off and of course
you know he wasn't right sometimes and
he he did get a lot of criticism but he
also apologized for what he did uh so
again first they try to science to
Second they try to take you down through
legal means and third they totally take
you out I think we're in the second
phase here I think what's happening to
him is is insane is is crazy I was even
critical of him a few years ago but but
again
if they're doing this to him why can't
we do the same to the corporate media
like but are they going after him
because I mean I feel like I mean what
what is their point is it because he was
one of the outspoken people for Trump
just like Steve Bannon I mean they've
gone after every single person that has
been influential in the Maga movement
and he has a huge fan base Steve Bannon
has a huge fan base they went after
Roger Stone they went after Mike Flynn
they've literally taken down by
everybody Milo they've taken about
anybody that's been associated with
Trump and they go oh look look at all
these indictments I mean even if it has
nothing to do with them but it's just
like they wipe out one of them at a time
with process crimes with not complying
or whatever Steve Bannon did I mean it's
just little tiny things but just to say
Hey look anyone who supports Trump yes
they target yeah man it's it's so crazy
how many media personalities who had big
shows and supported Trump gone you know
and that I mean and unrelated I'm a big
DeSantis fan I never liked the trials
but it's true when we look at the online
social media presence and and the memes
and the supporters of Donald Trump they
were the ones that got him into office
that's what I think they were the ones
who stood up and said hey this is
absolutely crazy here's some memes
here's a point of view here's my hot
take on this issue and it was
individuals like Loomer like Milo like
Alex Jones like Bandon that were there
on the Forefront that represented a huge
anti-establishment wing and slowly and
surely they were being taken out by The
Establishment as Donald Trump was kind
of watching it all transpire and didn't
decide to intervene and help out his
supporters which is another criticism of
him that I think is legitimate because
he had the power to to to just not only
just say something but to intervene to
pass executive orders to pass laws but
to more importantly also help set up
other infrastructure and other platforms
when when he saw all of his supporters
being censored and and and banned
everyone was telling them you're going
to be next he couldn't do an executive
order well he could have done a number
of he could have just try and invigorate
a different platform like he's doing now
exactly it's too late he could have went
to parlor right or he could have went to
truth social but he didn't do any of
that other people were telling him but
people were coming on to gab or mines
and I remember I was at the social media
Summit and someone stood up and said why
don't you sign up for an alternative
platform he goes which one which one and
then people were like there's there's a
bunch but I I guess my understanding is
Kushner told him not to do it not to go
to parlor well and was it Kushner that
um helped put elect or put all these
people in positions around him that
completely filled him like Jeff sessions
and no you know was I mean if there's
like one criticism I have about maybe
rounded himself with people I guess it
was just to appease and make himself not
look like he was coming in and just he
said he was going to drain the swamp but
he didn't
yeah you know he surrounded himself with
almost very swampy and and I think he
got in there and realized just how deep
that swamp was or at least how wide it
was it and it was it was a lot and he
didn't have the people who were going to
pull around him I mean that's for sure
and he hasn't been the best human
resources manager in that regard he
definitely put the wrong people around
him but that probably would be really
overwhelming going in there with so many
people against you to know exactly who
to trust well you're going in as a
businessman yeah not as a politician
you're not you're going in there you're
not willing to you know shake hands and
put your arms around everybody else and
say I'm going to scratch your back you
scratch mine and that's a very
Elementary way of saying what goes on
but there is an element of that you know
you're going to do me a favor I'm going
to do you a favor he went in there like
a bull in a china shop unfortunately I
think
I God God I don't care people come down
on me on this but I mean Trump went in
there to drain the swamp and end up
ended up becoming very swampy but he
didn't have the infrastructure around
him I don't think he became and I think
he became he did not well well it
depends uh operation warp speed and all
these other things it's all it's all on
people's personal beliefs and and at the
end of the day people will decide what
they think of him uh on their own
personal political uh ideas but uh one
thing that I did want to bring up is
that he didn't have the infrastructure
and he went along and I I think he
should have fired a whole bunch of
people he should have been like there's
a lot of bureaucracy here I don't know
who you are you're probably going to
screw me over you're probably going to
leak to the media fired you know it's a
clean house I think the answer to that
is and is it what do you all have like a
Beltway here or something like you need
to if if he's elected again or DeSantis
all the people they surround themselves
with needs to be like out of this DC
area yeah bring it inside get some
people from like Minnesota or I don't
Texas I would rather see blue collar
workers at the White House than
bureaucrats that were there eliminate
everyone just get get like get get coal
miners be like hey you're going to be in
charge of the EPA
but you got you said people from Texas I
said it's just not Rick Perry you know I
didn't know the guy who says Let's
abolish the department of energy and
then they put him in charge of the
Department of energy yeah not good
amazing yeah well but yeah but God I
really like y'all I should run for
office like as a Democrat because I
can't finish sentences
the thing the thing there is and when I
say you got Swampy the the whole deal is
like you said operation warp speed yeah
the you know until Trump comes out and
says I I was wrong he's never going to
do that but he pushed he pushed he
pushed he pushed he did it to appease he
pushed the vet and he still say that
word I don't even know the procedure he
still he's still telling people to do it
he brought it he brought the CEO of
Johnson Johnson out on the rally stage
the other day said he's a guy that makes
a lot of money I mean he makes a lot of
money and he plays booed Bill Gates is
bragging right now saying I told Trump
not to investigate the procedure he did
it I was telling him how to implement
policies and he wanted me to become the
science sir that's what Bill Gates is
saying today Donald Trump desperately
wants to take credit
he will not back down from that no he
wants it to be his great Victory he
won't back down he's his his I don't
know like people like his ego I guess I
don't understand that opponent of it you
wouldn't want to be married to that
right I don't understand why you want to
be you know you don't want to that you
don't want that guy to be your neighbor
but again and I think there's a big
portion of Americans out there that are
conservatives that do not want
government intrusion in your life they
got locked down lost their jobs you know
people screaming for reparations there
need to be there needs to be pandemic
reparations I mean that Emily Oster that
wrote that article last week or whatever
Halloween for the Atlantic said there
needs to be pandemic anesthesis amnesty
screw you there I mean until there's
real true reparations for that people
restored to their jobs there's there's
you know unless you can bring Grandma
back and you can't uh and and I look at
that I'm like Trump was a part of that
yeah he was a part of that he was a part
of allowing the he allowed fauci to go
too far I don't think he knew I think a
lot of people but see again that's the
argument that people I knew I I knew and
I'm nobody I knew yeah I knew Dr fought
you a soul of crap yeah as soon as he
was implementing policies saying black
lives matter protests are great and they
don't spread to the virus but but
lockdown protests are dangerous and we
shouldn't be doing those so as soon as
that happens Donald Trump should have
been like hey what are you doing why are
you saying black lives matter protests
are okay but anti uh you know lockdown
protester
is not okay exactly you can't go to
weddings you can't go to funerals so so
legitimate question then like what about
Trump made him completely blind to Black
we saw the riots happening in the George
Floyd riots how why didn't Trump he we
we know it was bad we knew Tom Cotton
said Insurrection act Trump did nothing
wasn't there at least out so outside of
trump not taking action on the rights
wasn't there an obvious contradiction
when you couldn't go outside because of
the lockdowns and even Trump was was
advocating for them I tweeted this
recently Donald Trump ragged on Sweden
over not locking down Sweden has had
less excess deaths and they didn't the
least amount yeah is one of the best in
the world where was Trump's mind and
lockdowns are important I am not going
to do or say anything about these black
lives matter protests right yeah the
scientists came out and were like yeah
it's it's well the establishment
scientists well there's propaganda
newspapers of Colorado they're like you
you see when when people protest for
Democratic causes this helps everyone
with covet but when they when they when
they protest things that that we don't
like that's bad and it was so bipartisan
it it's so partisan excuse me it was so
partisan it was so biased it was such a
slap in the face to anyone paying
attention and I I don't think Donald
Trump didn't see it coming I think it
was more obvious than ever I want to
point this out because we're going to go
to the next segment but uh you know and
I was thinking about Alex Jones having
to pay 1.4 billion I was like wouldn't
it be awesome if he won that Powerball
paid in full yeah but you know when you
take a number like that you look at that
I mean that that's basically a death
penalty here's a guy who he can't pay a
billion and a half dollars off can't do
it I don't think it's anywhere near here
that look they're not going to get a
penny from them and it's not going to
stop him no he's going to look there
there's already other people he's worked
with running companies right doing
similar things I'm buying supplements
right now we get it we get it Alex is
they're going to say you can't have
money and he's gonna say but someone
else can have money and that's how it's
always been he oh so what's he gonna do
start a new C Corp and the C corp's got
money and you can't sue the C Corp yeah
look they'll they'll try they'll Sue
they'll file they'll file they'll file
they'll never stop but they're really
not going to get anything from him
let's jump over to the story here we go
everybody from timcast.com SNL staff
writers boycotting this weekend's
episode over Dave Chappelle hosting
according to report there you go that's
about it they're not going to do the
show an unnamed Insider told the outlet
but none of the actors are boycotting so
the uh they say quote the room was full
of writers they all pitched ideas and
they seemed very excited about it Dave
is looking to have some fun so there uh
that was a rep from uh Chappelle saying
there's nothing going on but uh I don't
know what do you guys think they want
they want to try and cancel Dave
Chappelle well this story first came
from an anonymous source that again came
out didn't reveal who or she was and
said oh we're going to be boycotting
um Dave Chappelle and his staff are
saying hey we've been working with the
writers and the actors for the last
three days nothing's changed no one's
really boycotting us so I think this is
just like the kind of Netflix protest
that we saw of Dave Chappelle where the
media was hyping it up saying there's
going to be thousands of people there
and they were blasting it trying to make
it seem like it was a bigger cause and a
bigger reality than it actually was I
think this is also the same thing where
you have this kind of engineering of
this Viewpoint gaslighting people to
make them believe that people are
outraged against Dave Chappelle when in
reality Dave Chappelle is a comedy
genius and what he's done especially
with his stories about about trans
people has actually been kind of an
advocacy for them rather than a
criticism of it specifically when he
talked about his friend so for him to
get criticized for this is absolutely
absurd I don't think anyone's trying to
boycott him and if you are trying to
boycott a comedian for for telling jokes
you're taking life too seriously and
you're full of crap listen there you
know again Lenny Bruce and George Carlin
the likes of those they went to jail
over obscenity laws back in the 50s and
60s it's a damn shame that these things
are happening right now
there's two places in America you should
when you walk in the door you should
expect to be a little bit offended or at
least be made uncomfortable once the
church the other is the comedy show
right both of them have been watered
down so bad you know the comedy show
they're afraid to offend anybody uh the
they're they're afraid to tell jokes I
tell everybody when I get on stage
that's like look I don't care if you gay
straight black white fat skinny male
female trans Z gym her I don't care what
you are if I'm gonna make fun of myself
75 of the time I get to make fun of you
too ridicule is part of the job you
should be able to do that doesn't mean
you hate people doesn't mean you're mad
at people doesn't mean you wanna you
said this earlier they've never suffered
no they never have they know the way I
describe it is you know I'm sure
everybody in this room has gotten
physically hurt to some degree these are
people who live in pastel you know
beanbag rooms it was there was a
university I remember 10 years ago
whatever they created safe space rooms
where if a lecture was offensive you can
go in there's bean bags and fluffy
animals so if these people have never
actually fallen and scraped their knee
or anything like that when someone says
you're dumb they go
yeah it's the worst pain they've ever
experienced yeah on 60 Minutes this past
Sunday night they had the interviewer of
course was talking to a college
professor and he said how do you deal
with these tough topics he goes you
don't bring them up and he said but
isn't that what the university setting
is all about he goes it used to be
now you can't discuss listen our country
was founded on the ability to dialogue
disagree debate discuss all of these
different things and fight I mean John
Adams in in Thomas Jefferson at least if
you read their writings they hated each
other yeah right and that was okay they
were still considered the founding
fathers and we we're supposed to be able
to do that and then come back to this
thing called the constitution in the
Bill of Rights it says okay this is what
brings us together you might say
something that pisses me off but at the
end of the day that's okay listen my
father used to tell me all the time
talking about one of my brothers he said
yeah he's full of [ __ ] but if you listen
to him long enough every now and you
might find a pearl in the middle of it
well more importantly that's a very
important takeaway there sorry that's
all good just made me think of my
brother and I'm full of [ __ ] he is
um but but another thing that's very
important to note here is that comedy
heals a division in our society and when
you outlaw comedy when you make people
afraid to express comedy you perpetuate
a society where it's impossible to heal
any division in it and I think this is
why we're seeing such deliberate actions
against comedians against people trying
to make other people laugh against
people trying to bring people together
and this is just upsurge to see Dave
Chappelle attacked so much where he even
has to get serious during his comedy
special and address all this nonsense I
don't want to see that I want to see him
roll with the punches I want to see him
address a lot of the critics by making
fun of him and I think even he was
someone who is is an anti-establishment
guy who is seen as as a Critic of
society said okay now we have to get
serious during this comedy special and
I'm gonna have to address this seriously
I I hated to see that I thought it was a
capitulation and I think they're trying
to limit his expression and limit
everyone's expression because he's the
canary in the coal mine right now but I
do think you're right I think that's all
smoke mirrors and I don't think
anybody's complaining about it like just
like the divisiveness in this country
when you see your neighbor across the
street you're not fighting in the street
it really does come from the media
they're like well what do I want them to
fight about this weekend
I love that screen grab are you sitting
there holding that bottle of wine
fantastic shot right there uh but you're
right about that I mean nothing unifies
people should comedy and music should
bring people together I mean listen you
take Jim Jefferies right Jim Jefferies
Australian he he's everything I'm not
politically uh he goes on these long
binges about the the Second Amendment
how we shouldn't have guns and stuff it
I disagree with him 100 but I laughed my
ass off when I hear him do it because
it's funny because I first of all I've
got tough skin I I can disagree with
somebody and still laugh at what you're
saying you know you're not trying you're
not legislating me into something you're
trying to make me laugh yeah let's put
it in perspective here they roast me in
the comments all the time I love it I
saw that I saw it I was like damn and
it's and it's fine and it's okay because
I understand like hey this is this is
the landscape I'm gonna I'm still going
to express myself I'm not going to let
these comments affect me but at the same
time I know a lot of it is trolling and
trying to make me laugh and trying to
engage and and and it's totally
acceptable and it's totally okay and if
and and everyone should be okay with
criticism everyone should be okay with
people uh you know saying something
about them constructive criticism I
think is one of the most important
things in our society that is needed
more than ever and we don't have a lot
of that at all people are afraid of any
kind of criticism people are afraid of
any kind of responsibility and I think
we should normalize a society where you
could speak truth to power but that
right there is being eliminated from our
society and it sucks yeah
I saw the comments a second ago they
said CJ was in her 20s and I'm in my 50s
I'm liking this ratio
what they think I'm in my 20s yeah
several of them said make sure you keep
the jacket off it's fantastic
I'm in the comments uh yeah I I don't
think he's lying he he makes up a lot
that's okay go with it I'm drinking
tequila you can talk call me 20 any days
hey girl
but yeah love you guys
it's awesome to be a part of the
conversation what would we do without
those folks exactly we need people like
that yeah and if you're gonna criticize
me I know they're going to criticize
everybody else good we need that
critical thing you know I had people you
free I've always been a whatever
creative person I come up with Goofy
things all the time and people used to
say to me and it was the number one
phrase you have too much time on your
hands now now I joke and I say yeah I
got time to stand in line at the bank to
make deposits but you take Dave
Chappelle Dave Chappelle
is eating it up like I I've met Dave
Dave's a super nice guy I mean he's a
real person and you know
when you got Netflix paying you 70
million dollars to do an hour and you go
out there and you tape over four nights
however many he's doing two to four
nights to do this special and the bad
press sure you want everybody to like
you but they don't and as a comedian you
know it's like being in sales you're
going to be told no 65 percent of the
time 75 of the time this guy's worked in
crowds that hate his guts don't want to
laugh at him and so when the woke mom
comes after him
you know I talk about this in my book uh
am I crazy which talks about you know
living in a woke world and being
Unapologetic in the middle of it the
beauty of Dave Chappelle is the beauty
of Bill Burr the beauty of a Jim
Jefferies even on that side of things
they're Unapologetic yeah and that's an
extremely attractive thing in every
career path you take once you're saying
and doing things just to be liked you
become pathetic that's exactly and if
you're not questioning things if you're
not pushing the needle if you're not
pushing the envelope you're doing
something wrong when it comes to having
a conversation and I think that's what
we should all strive to do uh that's
see-through yeah it's it's obvious yeah
last week or whenever it was Luke Bryan
he's doing he's doing a show in Florida
he brings Rhonda santis on stage The
Crowd Goes Nuts and then of course the
online rereads go nuts you're saying oh
my God I can't believe you brought this
guy on he responds and said when I'm in
a state that's been hit by a hurricane
been devastated for me to bring the
governor on to help these people I was
raised to do that right that was my
paraphrase and I was like don't don't
apologize
don't effing apologize don't you do it
like when Joe Rogan apologized don't
apologize that's an admission of guilt
they sense weakness and they're gonna
pounce it don't do it you just admitted
guilt it's blood in the water yeah 100
that's why that's why our brand you know
everything Unapologetic Beyond
apologetic always and and I'm not saying
you did something wrong yeah to somebody
personally you insulted them or you hurt
them yeah go apologize that's not what
I'm saying I'm talking about the culture
at Large
own the Tweet own the [ __ ] you said and
just move forward
yeah absolutely it's kind of sad you
know because apologies are supposed to
be it's a good thing it's it's it's
mature you recognize you did something
wrong you say you know what I I'll own
up to that yeah but what's happened now
is they've exploited our Goodwill to to
such a degree that now it's like yeah
you're better off just not yeah they've
abused the better angels and and so like
if if this group if I say something
stupid which I'm apt to do if I say
something stupid and then and then we go
downstairs and Tim comes to me
individually and says dude that pissed
me off and I'm like hey I'm sorry man
I'm sorry that pissed you off I didn't
mean to piss you off that's one thing
but you know it for me to come back in
and bring you guys all back in the room
and say look I made this off the cuff
statement that I don't even know if you
heard it I need to apologize to all of
you I just made you aware of [ __ ] you
didn't even know you were aware of you
didn't even know if you heard it right
when you do that to culture at large
you're shooting yourself in the foot in
a big way now you're gonna you're gonna
have a tattoo on you for the rest of
your life you're marked yep you just
told everybody that you hear the apology
but they never saw the original they
were offended in the first place you had
to tell them they were offended yeah
that's what's wrong with our culture
right now you
situation what were we talking about uh
Jerry Jones the owner of the Dallas
Cowboys who goes for Halloween he
dresses up like a blind referee and
whatever the association Confederation
whatever it is the United World of blind
people is pissed off and they want
something they want an apology and I'm
like how the F did they know he dressed
up they're blind how did they know yeah
what he dressed up as for Halloween
yeah somebody had to tell them to be
offended yeah
that's a good costume the point is he's
a referee who couldn't make a good call
like it's a good joke why didn't the
referees associate you get pissed off
yeah seriously they have more right to
him they do they saw it
throw the flag man I don't know the way
things are going I'll just say
watch
these people have no principles and uh
it's exemplified by movies like black
panther 2.
because if I could explain what the
movie was about and spoil it it's just
like the ultimate hypocrisy you should
do among these
you should spoil it maybe I'll spoil it
in the after show for those that I mean
the movie literally just came out you
know what I mean we went and saw the
early showing we do it because one I'm a
big fan of the Marvel movies I actually
thought the story was was enjoyable
that's not the best but uh man was that
movie racist and they and the same thing
with the first one too it's like they
everything they claimed look
these cancel culture people they're not
offended they're not even offended they
just they're just bored online and it's
something to do and it makes them feel
powerful or part of something yeah if
they were offended they would watch
Black Panther too and be like yo we
better boycott this moment they're not
there's like the whole thing is just
insulting Mexican people
no
but I don't know what else can you say
let's do this let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
for you about 11 p.m and
for those who are commenting on the
videos we have these Post-it notes that
Milo yiannopoulos wrote about the
censorship YouTube rules and there's
like set it's like really funny it's
like you can't say this sad face and so
we're going to do is
uh we're gonna randomly choose people
who comment and then we'll we'll hit you
up and then we will uh send them out to
you so like legit we'll put in an
envelope we'll mail it to you you'll get
it you'll have a little little piece of
the show and look we have so much
garbage on this table right now I was
like let's let's here's how we can get
rid of it we can send it to people we'll
send you our garbage I mean not only
that look at Ian's side I mean you can't
really see it but it's a it's a disaster
it's like a bomb went off there's rocks
everywhere yo we'll start uh we'll set
this up we'll get something like some
kind of formal thing where we'll
actually put on the site and be like hey
one you know like 10 random commenters
we'll we'll pick and just send you guys
some stuff from the show because there's
not that many people comment
but I think it'll be really cool so
something we can do for you guys as
members and uh before we get into the
Super chats go to losingmymind.com
listen to our new song any way you want
to put on your playlists blast those
playlists because all of those plays
they rack up and then hopefully we'll
hit the we'll hit the Billboard Chart
because people really like the song if
you buy the song on iTunes for 69 cents
it also really helps and uh hopefully we
get a song about how the media is
garbage and trash in the billboard and
force them to write about it we're gonna
have a press release to put out and then
when they come out and they say
something like Fu you suck will be like
oh man no you know whiny babies but
we're we're not going anywhere all right
let's uh let's read some super chats we
got Chad who says rename the show my low
cast IRL best show I think that's from
yesterday yeah yesterday uh well no no
this is from today oh but uh Milo
basically just talked for two and a half
hours yeah pretty much yeah you know I
thought it was worth it though he hasn't
he hasn't done a show in like years and
he had a lot to say that was actually
really interesting no one heard his
voice in in such a long time seriously
user not available says Tim change your
shirt
well I did two days ago I was wearing
the button up now I'm wearing the Raglan
I have I have two outfits that's about
it
and I have like 50 of these shirts yeah
I was gonna say Bishop Cruz says
DeSantis is living rent free in Trump's
head his rant on Truth social was
unhinged why attack someone who has
never attacked him or even announce a
run for president while the election
isn't done
yeah
well it just doesn't make sense unless
you're trying to fracture the party
all right
monhoden says Tim is this yeah Tim if
Rhonda saidis is accepting money from
Ken Griffin he is not to be trusted Ken
Griffin runs Citadel they bankrupt
business to make their money by
manipulating the stock market he does
not give money without getting something
in return investigate this please
perhaps but I also wonder if DeSantis is
the to this guy the lesser of two evils
like uh-oh if Trump is in I'm in big
trouble decades isn't as bad as Trump
I'll take it you know and it's a fair
point to say why is that
I don't know I like DeSantis I think
DeSantis is a track record that's really
really good uh we'll see what happens
all right
Pat and the cat says Milo was the most
unintelligent guest you have ever had
strong feelings disagree strong feelings
yeah I know I think Milo was incredibly
smart yeah I don't agree with his
opinions you know he said to santis is
is awful and can't win and I'm like
DeSantis has a track record opposing CRT
uh supporting school choice his policies
on the lockdown there's a reason why
people were fleeing to Florida they like
what he was doing Milo is a Wordsmith
yeah so you even asked him about it
after the show didn't you yeah I was
like what how yeah I want this yeah
totally yeah
all right and and midi says voting
starts soon in Victoria Australia the
Libertarians from the liberal Democrats
who oppose the government over each need
volunteers to increase representation
our conservatives were feckless
bummer good luck
John says Tim and gang as I sit here
listen to this episode
I am continually refreshing the Cary
Lake Race and cannot stop cannot stop
worrying Will she end up winning will
with the great campaign she ran how
could she not
I wonder she's 20K down the it's getting
worse so they were saying initially that
they thought it would improve because
they were absentee drop-offs which are
not the same as early mail-in votes but
there were also many mail-in votes so
it's down to the wire
this is what happens when they do
Universal mail-in voting and that's it
and once you get into the Trap you can't
get out you can what do they say you can
vote your way into communism but you got
to shoot your way out yeah now in this
instance we're not quite there so carry
light can still win in Florida it's
obvious that uh Rhonda santis won by
double digits what we need is your
legislative state legislator you like
you guys got to win it at every single
level
and then um
you know hopefully uh hopefully just
wait hope for the best hope for the best
all right
let's see
Alex says Lord the pool if you may
answer this peasants Super Chat I must
ask why the hell is every podcaster I
follow now calling insults and offenses
a dig now where did this come from
what do you mean
that word's always been around yeah I
don't know no answer I don't dig it's a
slang term yeah I've heard it before
yeah people say it but uh you know
you'll notice this because they all
listen to the same show they'll listen
to each other yeah they'll start
adopting their own words lordpool I love
it
it is true Slavic Gypsy says as a
retired postal worker I object to going
postal let's call this for what it is a
fart in a church
okay
Charles Juan says I want to smash more
than the like button
what does that mean
well you can I think you know
you can smash the like button and the
Subscribe button that's that's that
that's what he meant right you want to
subscribe both later
something going over my head right now
all right
Kermit says I voted Chad in primaries
you should have come on timcast sooner
so there you go yeah that was the
difference
yeah it might have been it could have
been I wouldn't know it wouldn't hurt
that's for sure yeah
maybe maybe all right Joseph says four
more years cry harder with your short
memory
what is that a reference to
they want Trump to win you know here's
the thing listen I want Trump to win too
I'm gonna be real clear if it comes down
to you know Joe bidener it's not going
to be Joe Biden in 2024 it's going to be
Gavin Newsom right if it's that or Trump
I'm gonna go for Trump
if it's Gavin Newsom I'm gonna go for
Gavin Newsom if it's Carrie Lake running
for president I'm going to go for Kerry
Lake uh Ron DeSantis whoever I said I'm
gonna go for those pre those people
that's the bottom line but the thing
that people don't understand is we think
about it because we're in these circles
When Donald Trump ran in 2015 he had a
90 name recognition Across the Nation up
until a year ago Ron DeSantis was only
like 30 percent yeah he doesn't have the
national recognition outside of Florida
that people think that he does the
people in these circles who talk about
this all the time yeah that's a great
thing it is because politicos know him
people who are watching the news know
him and regular people when the media
comes out and it goes Rod DeSantis is a
fascist they're gonna go who who yeah
that's exactly that's a good thing yeah
it's going to play but also let's just
say Donald Trump runs right now he just
lost one of his biggest supporters who
could have been helping him out win the
State of Florida why does Ron DeSantis
want to help Donald Trump now if he does
run yeah which is going to hurt Donald
Trump in the long run he could have had
an ally that could have been helping him
yeah
send it says I heard Beto is running for
class president at Uvalde
oh jeez oh geez oh no
the uh realtor Steph says wrong what's
wrong with Abbott Pauling his
constituents he was hired to represent
the people so what if he spends money on
asking the people what they want rather
than typical swamp diving sellouts we
usually get
no because we elected him to be
instinctual everything is bigger in
Texas we wanted a Rhonda Sanchez type so
Abbott sticking his finger and they are
going whichever way the wind blows is
not being a decision maker not being
leader not being confident and that's
not
that's not what we should have we should
have the best in Texas I believe and we
don't
and to be clear on that I mean you when
you've got
Greg Abbott in Texas who has increased
the the budget the state budget by 40 in
the last
eight years now that he's been in office
um he's opened the door to Silicon
Valley he's you know we now have a
Facebook headquarters there Tesla is
headquartered there for Real uh he's
opened the door to Google Amazon all
these different ones he threw the door
open to Silicon Valley he gave a billion
dollar tax subsidy to Samsung which is a
South Korean company to come in his
whole thing about building a wall was
the Sham it was like three miles or
something well he did it was that was a
political stuff the camera Ploy he went
up there and put up two panels and and
that was it and they really did have
power to protect our border he does
Carrie Lake said day one but what is
whatever understands she understands and
she quoted the Constitution she
understands what kind of power the
governor has he takes money from people
we don't want him taking money from and
you know we don't we don't want to lead
her like that yeah exactly we wanted you
Chad well
this is taking money from people we
don't like
they all have and and again you've
you've got somebody I mean look you look
at the State of Texas we're a non-in
non-state income tax state but our our
property taxes are through the roof I
mean in metropolitan areas we're number
one in the nation we're number six uh in
overall in property taxes it's insane
they're through the roof and that's all
because we threw the door open to these
California corporations in all these
blue voters and then but also Pats
himself on the back sorry Trump took
money from Sheldon Anderson of all
people where these guys are taking money
from I I can't even make that argument
because they're all guilty uh yeah I
don't even I don't bring that up because
they're all guilty in that regard
um and and again you have the George
soros's who is that shadowy figure I
just say him because everybody knows
that name there are those shadowy
billionaire figures both on the right
and the left they donate to everybody
that way people can say oh look who
donated to that campaign so you almost
have to take the donors out unless
somebody is really going to be rigid and
say they're giving that money back we're
not going to accept that deal
unfortunately these folks running for
office don't do that no control says
fetterman is exactly what the DNC wants
he will vote the way they tell them and
won't ask for concessions they don't
want another Mansion except he might
accidentally say no instead of yes or
yes instead of no so we'll see I know
they're going to tell them what to do
and he's going to do the exact opposite
because he won't remember oh is that
rude
I think it's all right I guess but it's
true
all right Lester Leo says Taiwan is
going to have midterm election on
November 26th Tim you should send a
journalist there to observe how they run
a fair and secure election that's a
hefty ask uh short notice probably
outside of our capabilities at the
moment but um you know we're trying to
get there with your support as members
we will uh we will uh keep keep growing
all right Joseph says dead politicians
can't lie about their positions their
plank is obvious
ha ha
Travis fover says Democratic strategy
for elections is to maximize uninformed
voters best way to combat it would be to
publish legislation preventing
displaying a candidate's political party
on a ballot should be the number one
priority of Republicans I've said that
many many times you should not be able
to vote for parties
what do you guys think
eliminate the party listing on the
ballot so that no one can just vote for
party yeah do some research into the
issues and what they actually want as a
as a you know politician like if you
think about Cali's like Cali's thing it
had like uh it listed what's his name
um Rick what was his name Caruso it
listed him as like a billionaire and an
investor into properties Etc it doesn't
display anything about his like his
actual platform at all it just says he's
a billionaire investor and you know
people in California are not going to
like that RDS says please have a Milo
and Michael malice together it would
break the internet
yes we should get malice back on he
hasn't been on in a while yeah yeah that
was a great balance Tuesday night that
dude he's a wild one yeah absolutely
that's a really good idea um I will
reach out to
malice and Milo and see if we can do a
sit down oh that'd be a good one that
would be crazy we were asking who you
wanted to be on with that'll be fun have
a debate yeah I don't think it would be
a debate it might maybe
have a debate is that the one that got
in the fight on your show yeah
no it wasn't me it was it was it wasn't
my show either it was it was Glenn
Beck's special uh a little tiff people
can go watch it a little little thing
what was that argument about yeah it
erupted between uh Jason Whitlock and uh
Michael malice about it well you know
Whitlock is and God bless him I don't
want to talk for him I love Jason he's
uh he's not a political guy he's a
culture guy you know he's with ESPN he's
a writer and it's fantastic and really
smart guy I got a show on The Blaze and
he he made the off the cuff statement
that that arguably Joe Biden's the worst
president in the history of the United
States when you know we all say that he
wasn't you know again he wasn't speaking
and so again malice is going to say
Woodrow Wilson he's going to say is he
worse than is he worse than Barack Obama
and Jay and Jason's like look I'm just
looking at the results of what I'm
saying and Malice was said you know
Michael said look the data doesn't line
up with that you know and and Jason was
basically like I don't care what your
data says I'm just saying this is what
I'm seeing in the streets and so it got
you can go watch it you're making it
sound so benign I know I am because
they're not here and it's not fair for
me to talk about that it got tough well
I'm not a part of the network I can
gossip if I want I'm just saying but see
here's the unfair thing because neither
does Mike Mike doesn't work for the
blaze either and he kind of made a
spectacle of the thing and uh pushed it
pushed it pushed it until Jason had to
go and collect his Christian
sensitivities but but it got heated but
at the end of it look it's two guys that
have the same vision and the same at
least not maybe not the same vision but
they they're going at the same goal with
maybe two different directions they got
a little heated but that you know [ __ ]
that happens Wilson was the worst
president no question about it he is the
reason we're in the situation we're in
right now is Woodrow Wilson and all the
rereads online that are bitching these
experts online they don't even know what
Woodrow Wilson did but they need to go
check it out yeah all right Billy says
Luke quote I'm not a DeSantis Fanboy
redkowski who are you trying to fool I
in this video
in this podcast I literally told you
that DeSantis endorsed candidates that
didn't win which a lot of people didn't
didn't know about which I think is fair
to talk about when we're criticizing
Trump and I also told you it should be
critical of him and I have very critical
right no I'm I'm very I I'm just like
Luke DeSantis too handsome just too good
his policies that dude loses 20 pounds
and I'd hit it
hey we should be critical of every
politician that's what I always said but
when it comes to the record I I think
Ron DeSantis has been great on covid
great on on a lot of the anti-woke stuff
what he does with foreign policy we
still don't know criticize every product
politician hold their feet to the fire
no matter what there's still things
about DeSantis I don't know that I'd
like to see exactly say that uh I want
to know who's who is back in that I mean
f Paul Ryan I don't give a rat's ass
about Paul Ryan I don't understand why
Paul Ryan's even but what's his foreign
policy going to be like we don't know we
don't know and here's the thing and
Jason probably why it would be good for
them to go at it because it's like when
they say competition breeds Excellence
you'll get to see what you know yeah
let's have that debate let's have that
conversation and I will say that on the
international on the international scene
uh in that scale Donald Trump is Battle
tested Rhonda Santos is not
um we've seen what uh Donald Trump can
accomplish in that in regards to that he
keeps people in check he kept him at Bay
he was hard on Russia I mean he was and
he keeps people talking and and the
whole thing he he's able to put his hand
up here and say look at this look at
this look at this while he's getting
work done down here and he can say the
most off the cuff stuff and boom there
it is we don't know what Ron DeSantis is
capable capable of in that role I tend
to believe he'd be okay
but again he's a little more polished we
like that
uh maybe he's a unifier I don't know if
America can be unified but we'll see all
right Diane Reynolds says Tim would you
mind explaining how the Democrats
benefit more from rank Choice voting I'm
from Maine and we have many people who
moved here because of covet 19. so it's
not so much that it benefits Democrats
it benefits the status quo
so if you have a an establishment
Democrat and an establishment Republican
and a Maga Republican ranked Choice
voting effectively ensures outside
candidates cannot win
so what will happen is you'll have a
bunch of conservatives and they'll be
like okay you know look I don't like the
Maga guys so I'm going to vote
Republican and my second choice will be
the Democrat because I really don't like
the the Maga guys that's basically what
conservatives don't like about it what
else can happen is let's say you know
the one idea is rank Choice voting can
help Libertarians win and and it can I
would probably vote libertarian on
ranked Choice voting followed up by a
market candidate or something like that
many people probably would so there is a
net positive here depends how you look
at it but
when you have ranked Choice voting most
people are going to vote for their
unique political party
uh green party or libertarian and then
those votes fall off and then they just
coalesce back into democrat or
republican establishment what what a lot
of the Maga people are hoping for is
that in the constitutional republic
system minority parties can still win
like Abraham Lincoln for instance who
many people say is one of the greatest
presidents I've ever had whatever your
opinion is on them he was a minority
president he won because of a split vote
if we had ranked Choice voting he would
not have won and then who knows what
have happened United States so I don't
know I'm not going to pretend that I
know absolutely everything or the
mathematical probabilities of ranked
Choice voting but those are some of the
concerns
what do you guys think about it you guys
like rank choice no no opinion
no I just I just go back to the whole
thing that look people are too swayed
they're too swayed by things that don't
matter whether it's the whether it's the
party line or whatever it is putting the
you know
we're living in an age of tyranny
we are being ruled by big government I
don't know there's any way we're not
United I don't feel I look as a Texan I
don't feel United with California most
of it at least their bureaucracy I don't
know I don't feel United with New York
or Northern Illinois Oregon Washington
it's it's a frustrating deal I mean
that's the world we're living in right
now you know I I've I don't want to get
into that but I it's just
it's a frustrating deal Catherine
scofborg says as a gen Zer I don't think
many understand how incredibly woke gen
Z is they despise capitalism love
abortion and are very energized to vote
this will continue to have a big impact
it's actually a relative relatively new
phenomenon because for a while uh gen Z
actually was slightly more conservative
according to the polls as four years ago
what I think changed is Tick Tock so
this is a strategy that's been around
for a long time and I'll explain to you
how it works
you make a mobile app
you run advertisements at uh of of
people on it doing things you hire
actors you take posts you make videos
you advertise it to high schools
kids sign up for it you give those kids
fake followers fake likes and fake
comments to make them feel validated and
then they start saying something like
Whoa I'm on I'm on redkowski space and
I've Got 5 000 followers on Instagram I
only have a hundred I'm gonna keep using
Rutkowski space then they go to their
friends and they're in high school and
their friends are like uh you know I
post this on Instagram I don't use
Instagram you don't no I'm on rokovski
Space why I Got 5 000 followers how many
followers do you have what you have 5
000 followers yup oh dude I just gained
another 100 and they're all fake but
these kids don't know this then all the
other kids in the high school are like
I'm gonna sign up dude sign up and I'll
shout you out and you'll get followers
the company gives them one more fake
accounts eventually you end up with kids
who think they have a million followers
all the comments are fake but this
attracts the real high school kids to go
on it then you algorithmically feed only
the ideology you want those kids to have
super easy I was uh I was talking to
people about this uh 2016. 20 I'm sorry
I was talking about I was talking about
people about this in 2013. because we
made a mobile app called uh tagley
in uh 2013 and it was uh it's an app
where it doesn't exist anymore it might
still exist but you take a picture and
it automatically includes metadata so
it'll say a text text you want to
include like your Twitter handle time
date location all through the phone take
the picture it's instantly there you can
post it and it was context for
journalists and we were talking about
creating a social component and uh you
know basically people were telling me
it's impossible to make a new mobile app
that's a social network you're it's a
waste of time and I explained to them
like dude
I used to work in non-profit fundraising
let me tell you what you're doing wrong
and explain how this works we don't want
to do it but I'm like this is what these
companies do we know other companies
have done it this is how they do it
it's crazy right so I'm all for
brainwashing as long as it um benefits
me so why don't you start a new app
because people won't use it
um I mean if you give all those high
schoolers the fake followers and then we
feed them
I believe the CEO of Reddit admitted to
running bot accounts to comment on
people's posts on Reddit to make it seem
like they had users when they didn't
they're getting engaged so they exactly
so people would be like oh people are
talking to me I'll use this app think
about what so let me ask you do you
think the government hasn't implemented
that plan to control the minds of young
people of course they have yeah
absolutely of course they have and we
know in 20 I'm sorry it was in 2011 I
believe we learned the US government was
purchasing fake accounts from private
security contractors to uh mimic real
people they're called sock puppets so
they can control public opinion Elon
Musk bought Twitter and they're all too
salty about that because that means I
got to pay eight bucks for every bot
they want to operate yeah it's a lot of
money
Elon knows what's up they're pissed
that's why they're like we're gonna
we're gonna investigate this National
Security and you're gonna pay eight
bucks it's gonna be for every account
and if y'all notice that when you get on
Twitter if you go to the verified deal
like it used to be blue check people
only like you can check now it's garbage
mentions and now and then you had or you
had your followers you had your mentions
and you had verified and if you get
through there they were all verified
blue check mark people now it's I don't
I don't know how the hell they're
supposedly verifying I mean they're made
with 18 person they're 18 followers that
are showing up in the deal this is this
is a terrible mistake Elon made and
hopefully he fixes it when I was excited
for him opening up verification it was
not that he would just say you can pay
eight bucks and you are verified it was
that people had to prove they were a
person they were a real person now
what's happened is there's been a bunch
of accounts that have imitated Nintendo
and other companies and his response is
LOL we banned them and they paid me and
I'm like dude
a lot of people I know who are verified
have complained about this and all the
people who complained we agree
verification should be open to everybody
the problem is you used to be able to go
to your your if you're verified you can
go to a verified only Tab and click it
and see only verified accounts
commenting liking sharing Etc so a lot
of these were your colleagues your
friends people you worked with or people
you needed to hear from now you go on
and it's like troll Smasher 53 and
they're they're posting slurs or they're
doing whatever they're saying a lot of
nonsense there are a lot of people who
are saying things that are fine but I
already had a mentions tab I don't need
mentions tab two I can't use them so
I've got 1.4 million followers on
Twitter my mentions tab is useless I go
to it it's just chaos the verified tab
was neatly ordered because it was only a
smaller it was a much much smaller
amount of people interacting with me now
it's just a spattering mess of tens of
thousands or whatever it doesn't make
any sense watch Chad at Lone Star CJ
but uh so Elon needs to fix this the
other thing is Elon really doesn't
understand
um
so these social components uh to to
gamification
right now if you are a uh if you were
previously verified if you click
someone's verification badge it will say
this account is verified for being
notable in these spaces if your Twitter
blue verified you click it it'll say
this account is verified for subscribing
to Twitter blue
that has created an elite versus pleb
system already Elon responded to this by
saying we are going to get rid of it
it's going to say Legacy verified could
be real or could be bogus and then it's
going to say blue
that was the stupidest thing he could
have said in my opinion and I like Elon
I'm not trying to be mean but when he
announced that there will be limited
edition Twitter accounts that's what he
did I was like yo you just made it
infinitely exponentially more Elite
versus pleb it's one thing to say this
person was a news personality so he
verified them it's another thing to say
that you're an OG with a never with a
badge that can never be attained unique
limited edition only for you I was like
you think I'm gonna sign up for Twitter
blue and lose a legacy badge dude I got
if I had I used to have a bunch of first
edition Charizards from back in the day
yeah it's useless but first edition
Charizard yeah that's great Elon
basically what he needs to do is make
all of the badges the same in fact what
he should do right now is he should
delete every Legacy badge all of them
and then say sign up for Twitter blue if
you're on a badge
but instead it's like bro you want to
tell me I'm going to have that you know
that rare limited edition can never be
achieved wow it's like I used to play
World of Warcraft and they're items you
can only get that were promos and stuff
it's like those are those are you keep
those man those are amazing Elon wants
to put a badge on my account that no one
else can ever get ever
wow why would you get rid of it yeah
never yeah I don't know the frustrating
thing about it is if if it was easy for
people to go out there and get a large
following on social media then everybody
would do it right there's a reason
certain people do that and it happens
whatever nerve they struck or whatever
Accord they strummed it resonated with
people and they got it you're you're in
essence taking away all that work that
went into building that following right
and you're giving a certain verification
badge to people who again like I said
the the you know the person with 18
followers in a cartoon Avatar as a
profile picture that who knows who you
are or what exactly or why what did you
monetize a table I think what he's
trying to do is by putting a a pressure
on Bots
it gets rid of them the idea is that you
need to sign up through a credit card so
you know that verification means the
real person but that's not this is my
mistake I thought the Bots even the blue
check marks it seems like the Bots would
be just like the regular people in the
comments they are there I thought what
he was going to do is he was going to be
like you sign up then you set your name
send in your ID and now we know who you
are who you are I thought he was
verifying human beings I didn't think he
was going to make like you know Domino
Man pizza guy 43 with a picture of a cat
eating waffles verified because you've
we've already seen people pay all that
all that he's doing is making it so the
spammers and the Bots have to pay him
money to do it I get it he's going to
make a lot of money off and he's
probably betting on that but it doesn't
make the user experience good it makes
it bad true all right let's grab uh
we'll grab just a couple more today I
mean a couple more right now Amber black
says pool redkowski 2024. what do you
say Luke shall we I'm never gonna never
never gonna happen
I think if like people voted to force
Luke to run he would flee to Mexico
well I don't know
Mexico is pretty beautiful but yeah she
doesn't like Mexico Iran
all right PJ says everyone tweet hashtag
kid rocktimcast and ask Kid Rock to come
on timcast IRL and play We the People
don't tell me how to live and Born Free
that'd be cool I'll be down for that the
new the new studio is going to have a
music section excuse me
we're going to build out an area where
we can do live music so it's going to be
really great and uh fix Lighting and
Sound and all that good stuff my friends
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we have a members only show coming up
for you at about 11 p.m and we're going
to be selecting random members who
comment and send them keepsakes from the
show like Post-it notes written by Milo
himself and other knickknacks and also
this is the last one the last time I
will ask you to support our song because
it's over in two hours billboard will
stop tracking the song and we're hoping
to smash into the Billboard Hot 100 it's
a big ask but it would be great if we
could say you know our second song it
was directly insulting you and people
liked it so much it sharted please write
about how much people don't like you the
press release we put out was was a
sarcastic insult to journalists for all
the problems they've created and uh go
to losing my mind.com you can listen to
the song It's a big chart list of all
your favorite platforms you can buy the
song genocide Losing My Mind by timcast
on iTunes it's 69 cents that really
helps the most and you can listen to the
song and watch the hilarious music video
on YouTube this is it it's the last
promo so this is the last chance so uh
thank you all so much for your support
with uh with our first song our second
song I really do appreciate it you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast CJ do you want to
shout anything out
um yeah you can follow me at Lone Star
CJ and I want everyone to go check out
the real Women's Club
realwomensclub.com realwomensclub.com
brand new it is
what's your website um you can find me
at watchchad.com uh headed over to Port
Charlotte Florida next week doing five
shows in four nights Dasani theater and
of course the Chad Prather show on Blaze
TV or just the chat right there show on
YouTube straight up right there thank
you guys so much for coming on this was
awesome this is really fun my YouTube
channel is we are change I've been doing
videos there for 14 15 years lots of
crazy videos on there I'm really proud
of the video I did today check it out
I'll be answering comments on there
right now youtube.com forward slash we
are change and I'll see you guys in the
comments from search.com we'll see you
all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out cheers